hi everybody Welcome to the 300 miles
burrito buff
is doing his weigh-in right now not love
Dad I'm frazzled
throw it out
it's up it's up I can't hear it oh okay
one second I'm doing a million things
right now one second one second well
welcome everybody
he's introducing a b
itch
is he fighting a b
let's go
Warriors Warriors
and he's from Dearborn Michigan Abe is
also known for skateboarding around
hotels and he is incredibly
irresponsible
yes AB told me in private that he would
take anabolic steroids if he had to to
beat dad that is a true statement he
actually did yeah well he's clearly not
on no offense
I mean he's in great shape
next up
we have William Haynes so wait they
didn't actually do the weigh-in they're
just they're just introducing all right
yeah this is the introduction
the weigh-in goes down all right so
actually I really want to see them
oh God oh God side by side hopefully it
didn't need too many AV burritos
right right am I right last year he had
the bulk up and this time he doesn't
need to so he should be in good shape
welcome everybody sorry about that crazy
intro there it's kind of
Panic started the show
here of course with the Beautiful the
ever gorgeous
thank you the on the always internally
lovable breakfast burrito
[Music]
Eva I love you you are stunning you are
confident thank you thank you look at
this I started playing Poison by Britney
Spears when she came in
like a hot leopard
[Laughter]
so hey Gabe one sec there bud
so um you went down to the you told me
you went down to the train station you
went to the train yes
I turned around and this guy behind me
was just taking his pants off just like
totally going you went there to take
photos yeah now take paint the picture
for me you're like at the loading I was
at the at the part where you're about to
put your ticket in and you go past the
okay I mean he was past that he was
inside it was inside and he was and
where was he [__] was it around a
corner next to the wall but there was no
corner it was just a straight wall did
he look homeless or did he look
something like Zach no
yeah but because you made it but it
wasn't like a coroner it was very like
very much like where everybody enters
and so was his dick out was his pants
were fully done I saw the backup he saw
his nuts it's always I saw his butt he
saw his butt butt did you see poop
coming out I turned around when I saw
the butt well there you go you get the
real experience
[Applause]
[Music]
let's see tomorrow Yay good job fun yeah
thank you also can I talk about the hair
thing
um I'm the only reason I'm afraid to
talk about because I don't want people
to start figuring out who is it okay
fairness I don't want them to even
bother yeah and today we have a bit of a
skeleton crew because of course a b
and Lena are gone but then uh Ian might
be taking off mid-show to Coachella for
us to do a sketch for the show yeah
and he might even be staying with
White Cloud Gabe oh really debunking
together
whoa [__] baby you guys are going to
Coachella game
yeah I'm at the child right now we're
just doing some shopping for the house
oh you're at Coachella I thought you
were at Target it looks like no you said
he's doing somewhere targeting Coachella
oh he's not at Coachella yet I mean they
probably have to Target there
targeting Coachella wow let's say that
have you been to Coachella Gabe I was
there last year
fun times
yeah it's pretty fun not that good
though huh a little overrated it's like
walking it's a big Festival it's walking
bathrooms are so decent oh no see that's
right no offense because I know it
people love that but to me that's like
hell on Earth it's like walking it's hot
there's [__] nasty toilets you have
to wait in line for [__] super loud
pretty much there oh yeah but you will
try not to eat wait I'm not anywhere oh
you're not going anymore okay
right
so yeah don't drink that's your advice
Don't drink don't eat much so I'll help
you create the urge to go
I understand your your heart is in the
right place okay but I find that advice
just a little concerning because if
you're outside walking in the Sun not
drinking might actually well I I'm being
a little extreme but it could actually
kill you yeah yeah
no we don't see that happening heat
stroke is a conspiracy
I just have to like tough it out I guess
yeah but please drink lots of water okay
okay yeah
are you excited to uh see any particular
artist there
um I'll come out of a surprise baby
and so you you guys actually hooked up
so Ian was planning to go down there
he's gonna shoot a sketch for the show
and he is so hardcore man
he was or he might still depending off
Gabe has room go down there by himself
and pitch a goddamn tent really yeah
because Sam's like I'm not doing that
[__] and you know I don't blame her for
that
I'm not doing that [__] you know what I
mean
that's like that's like hardcore
hardcore Coachella fans yeah in front of
in front of the um festival and just
Camp there I'm not that girl I need I
need some I need some luxury some
warrants that's what I'm talking about
that's white classic
with a bathroom and I I king sized bed
and I'm good that's what I'm talking
yeah you need your Glam Squad
yeah you know you worked hard in life
you deserve to kick your feet up oh yeah
I suppose I got my VIP pass I'm good you
got that VIP pass game
yeah you guys secure that or did you buy
it
uh we have I have I have some
connections with friends you got
connections what yeah
[__] baby VIP baby yeah [__] in a
greenhouse uh porta potty baby [__] in
the porta potty and [__] all over the
toilet [__] [__] push over somebody in
a porta potty and make them
[__]
yes are you excited to see any of the
performers like who are you most maybe
Bad Bunny or somebody somebody like
something 180 something like that cool
so um yeah as I was saying Ian kind of
impress slash shocked me I was like Ian
you don't have to do this
but he's super down to go a pitch a ten
uh what's your plan Ian um yeah just go
pitch a tent hundreds thousands of
people because like for me
well I'm not like I'm not comfortable
going and making new friends in that
situation like I would feel so so
awkward and out of place I would hate it
oh my God it's like my nightmare
well there's probably a lot of people
that you're gonna know right that's
gonna be there he's in tent world
you know it's just sort of No it's it's
more so that I have no friends okay
gotcha I have no friends I have no
support same brother
in the dirt the dust and the grime
I mean yeah Tent City you're like a
refugee camp people probably be [__]
in the sand
begging for water people I am people I
am people [__] in the sand that's
what I'm saying well I said by the way I
said Ian we'll get you a hotel you know
what I mean he says and Ian told me
there's no lodging no lodging
do you guys know that Frank Ocean is
going to be on next weekend
weekend too yeah did you not want to go
to that one
well so Gabe isn't the only one we did
get a VIP hookup from our friends
who is performing oh okay tomorrow okay
so I reached out to Mark a good great
guy friend of the show because I wanted
to get Ian yeah good access gotcha and
he hooked it up he was super gracious so
we love Mark rubier and uh we love him
and he got you like a press pass Ian uh
it's like a VIP pass thing yeah so you
might see gay back there you guys have
equal access hopefully hopefully Gabe is
not you know too much of a big shot
you know as I walk by and he's probably
games probably got the uh artist pass
yeah and he's here right now do we want
to put him on the spot
I'm gonna be having a good time
he's already he's already at Coachella
in his mind right he's living it up out
there at Target
[Music]
[__] baby [__] yeah
well anyway good luck out there uh Ian
Sam you're not going to camp out right
that's not happening no I don't know if
I would even
I don't know you're changing it now
um I was never camping well that's for
damn sure
but I don't know you were the one that
wanted to go rough it on a ranch the
other day that's no Dan it's luxury you
don't get it I feel like you're the
whole Southern you know Rough and Tumble
it might be some Stolen Valor going no
the ranch is a luxurious place you stay
in a luxury cabin it's like Glam
difference
Sam stop being baby and take a [__] in
the sand like everybody else I don't
even know if I would enjoy Coachella to
be honest I don't know I'm sure I've
never been I don't know either I just
don't know I go to bed at nine o'clock
like I don't know if I can stay up for
Frank starts at 10. Frank starts at 10.
I will be asleep yeah you're in rem like
that's like
I'm happy to see that a lot of people in
the chat are Frank oceaners yeah he's
super popular yeah I'm lately I'm like
obsessed it's like all I listen to It's
amazing that's the main reason I'd even
go sleep
[Music]
I saw him once at fyf and he started a
song over because he didn't like the way
he sounded really oh [__] wow is it
embarrassing no it was funny he was just
sitting on the edge of the stage she's
like no restart that's cute I love him
love that for him
yeah he's great yeah super talented
talented
hey this doesn't run around Southern
California
my eyes don't shed tears and some [__]
in the desert
I feel like dude we're gay man he just
wants to he wants to get on with his day
we should like him because um there's
actually somebody else calling in right
now Gabe we love you we I I hope that
you guys are able to Rendezvous with Ian
that'd be fantastic
but I'm sure you guys are going to have
a great time and Nick Nick's gonna take
good care of you out there
all right
[Applause]
[__] baby [__] baby
[Music]
[__]
all right guys have fun okay we love you
I here's Gabe with his artist passed uh
on stage with what looks like Harry
Styles that's clouded up that's clouded
up oh wow wow you got that VIP pass bro
wow that photoshop is like or I mean no
he's really there you could tell
all right so someone else is calling in
yeah it's I I wanted
I wanted to work give you a heads up but
I figured it might be better as a
surprise was it my mom
um give me one second true nice uh not
quite not quite
who's calling in
somebody that I wouldn't expect or
someone that I don't like you wouldn't
expect
on the phone hold on a second that was
like glitching out right now give me a
panic attack
oh yeah yeah come on oh man work with me
baby here we go yo it's not shoe nice is
it because that's freaking me out it's
not actually nice okay
um yeah hold on my zoom is like
completely free well just don't the [__]
off if it's not working I don't know who
it is but gotta give uh Dan a shout out
because he's switching right now with
her of the day but wait what are you
doing so yeah what are you doing I'm
doing a lot I'm he's getting ready to go
take that break yeah he's just waiting
now that you're switching put the camera
on Ian God for God's sake okay he's been
doing it and it's making all I see is
love I know because okay dude Dan you're
like that everybody stop yelling at me
I'm back 220 feet alone I was giving you
flowers Dan you're that guy from
Spirited Away who who's got like 20 arms
I wish I had 20 bucks right now all
right hold on I'm only seeing love
Dan is a great guy come on Dan he's Dan
is this guy right now yeah my computer
is like legit walking wait then you're
missing the glasses
do you have a little hamster friend that
we could probably potentially put on
your shoulder oh that would be so cute
cam do you have any hamster friends
yeah if you would yeah do you want this
then yeah if you could just go in it to
him put your balls in my mouth
that's totally unrelated
oh what is this that is just to get you
in character as uh
you guys are good man oh
let me see I can't see Dad because it's
just like I can't take this down I
literally can't take that off the screen
I can't fix it
which I love I I'm I'm in uh task
manager right now I'm trying to force
quit Zoom but task manager isn't working
either I think my computer is uh going
happy with me right now and Ian is just
sitting back relaxing and you're not
doing [__] to help
can I pull back the uh Power
I have to go plug a bunch of [__] in oh
this is uh uh kamaji kamaji your kamaji
Dan yes
okay um okay I don't know what to do my
computer I cannot close Zoom you are
gonna have to look at love for us to
show well that's not a brilliant option
restart your computer or something the
computer is used on the show but like I
can't do the show like this I can't do
this I can't do the show
oh my God
no it won't it won't but it'll turn on
this is like Dan except with all of his
arms broken
foreign
all right let's take the jacket off and
get to work then
sorry
[Music]
yeah okay well while we wait for that
call in uh I will say this oh [__]
um a b is being weighed right now oh oh
my God okay okay two seconds two seconds
gotta break through we've had a
breakthrough okay standby so wait Amy's
being now we can finally speak to the
special guest that you're really excited
to talk to oh dude I told you not to let
him call I I know you whoa whoa whoa
whoa okay hold on whoa whoa whoa who why
is this happening there hold on who is
this guy again listen he I didn't want
to let him on but he was crying to me he
had he he kept reaching out he had his
producers reach out like four of them
who's your boss I said I don't want him
back I honestly I felt bad I felt Oliver
what do you want now that you tricked
Dan into letting you on why the [__] are
you calling into the show after
explicitly said I do not want to talk to
you anymore
first of all I just wanted to say Gila
it is so nice to see you
I understand that Easton yeah
okay
just dude just say what you have to say
bro I I have a show to do
things have been rough lately man you're
wearing a trash bag why are you so cover
it up what's going on I've been
designing I spent a lot of time overseas
I've been in Brazil for the last few
months and um kind of been just going
through it and um I just you know
first of all I wanted to say you know
enough about me how are my godsons how
is Michael and Tommy don't worry about
them they're fine
um is that a clan Hood Theodore and
Bruce are doing oh wait what it looked
like he was wearing a clan hood No what
the hell is wrong because hey that's
what it looked like
I'm about to leave
if that's what he's wearing
all right yeah they're fine yeah theater
and Bruce are doing great they're really
cute so what so what's going on with you
you're in Brazil doing designer [__]
what happened music didn't work out well
it didn't really work out out there and
um I'm back in LA and uh I was staying
on my manager's couch for a while and
basically
he's moving in with his girl and so now
I was just you know I'm kind of down
down and out a bit and I was gonna see
if maybe I could stay at the pool house
no is that something no might be open
too
I don't think so I think that it's um
we don't have furniture in there right
now
you don't even make excuses I don't need
Furniture I'm good I I'll bring my own
stuff I've got some pads and stuff
you know what we'll talk we'll we'll
talk about it after the show and we'll
see uh what we can do but we'll get back
to you well I just yeah basically the
situation and not to you know make this
too much about me but essentially
I made some bad bets
um I owe my bookie a lot of money and so
I'm just kind of going can we turn the
sound effects off this is a pretty
serious situation uh Zach go ahead and
put down the circus music just for just
a moment yeah I'm trying to keep your
finger on the button
so yeah I made a couple bad bets I've
been getting into horse racing oh Oliver
horse races horse racing that's like the
lamest way to lose all your money that's
not even cool yeah
I thought you were cooler than that I've
made some mistakes along the way I'm not
gonna lie and um so you're like broke
well it's even worse than that I owe
money around the town and not just to a
couple different bookies but also the
IRS that's wild you know Oliver come on
bro how much money are we talking
it's not a lot it's just you know it's
just a little bit over 600 Grand and I
was just gonna see if maybe you could
just make a small loan to me just
something you know I'm good for the
money man I'll pay you back Atlantic
Records owes me a lot of money and I
think that if maybe like I don't know
you might have a little extra floating
around I just need it's a little bit
over it's like six 100 plus a little bit
of change uh but if you twenty thousand
give or take
[Laughter]
Oliver what I don't have that money yeah
what makes you think that we would just
have that much money sitting around yeah
no no I don't got money that much liquid
in my bank liquid cash
you sure we couldn't pull it out of one
of the teddy pressure counts I've been a
great I was a model I helped with the
campaigns I was an endorser a brand
endorser I never really got cut in on
that and I was just wondering if maybe
you could give me a little up front for
some of the future stuff I mean I could
give you a couple thousand but I'm not
I'm not you don't do that for me yeah
I'll give you a couple of thousand I
feel like I could turn a couple thousand
into a lot so it could help but who you
better you betting on Buttercup or Big
Balls McGee or I don't know
is Ethan Klein Gila Klein you guys I've
been a long time supporter and I know
I've been you know laying low lately
I've been you know overseas and whatnot
but I just wanted to say you know if
there's anything that you guys can
donate to a close friend a Godfather of
the children you know I've done so much
for the family
you take canned goods I mean we could
probably swing some candy
stuff like that
Ramen ramen noodles
but the shrimp the nice ones I'm hungry
thinking about it
let me get this straight Oliver you've
been watching the show you saw that we
got 620
000 from bbtv no no no no and now you're
calling in trying to beg me for money
dude wait what did you what happened
here what I must have missed something
on the Internet you just thought to ask
me randomly for just a little bit over
six hundred thousand
wait wait go back what were you saying
about 620 000. yeah we got 620 000 from
bbtv
shut the front door you kidding nope all
cash
full cash huh yeah I'm just sitting in
my bank account what are we gonna do
with the money what's the plan we right
yeah we the plan is being debated
actually
we could take you out we're gonna be
taking a trip to Japan Oliver actually
dinner would be great and Japan's
awesome I've spent a lot of time there a
big fan of yeah we will have yeah I can
show you guys the ropes I've actually
spent a lot of time there uh that would
live there for about six months oh you
are you gonna be playing out there or
something oh that's funny you say that
um yeah I actually am but I'm not
supposed to talk about that right now
okay because then probably your tour
manager is probably the one to ask about
that well no the issue is we're just
trying to raise some funds for the the
trying to do a job this is sad come on
dude you bet calling me you're begging
for money you used to be on top of the
world this idea man a trip with us
oh I feel like I'm part of the crew you
know I feel like I'm one of the the crew
don't you think wouldn't you say this is
hey Dan this is why I said
do not take his call he's calling in
he's slowing down the show he's being
ridiculous he's begging me for money
Oliver I'm sorry I don't I don't mean to
embarrass you but dude Ethan he was
[__] sobbing on the phone last I
don't care he always I I told him no
over and over again okay guys dead air I
know no it's boring dude he's always
crying and crying why to get on the show
he'd be like oh [__] broke and
whatever I was in Brazil oh [__] I know
I never did to say that Oliver but he he
was grilling me I'm sorry
thank you Dan what if Oliver agreed to
shoot a video with you Ethan where he's
singing Ethan Klein is my hero okay now
we're talking real hero are you familiar
with that video
no what is it okay that's I like this uh
idea Ela how much are we talking because
I think we could for the right price you
know I think make something work here
you give me a quote and then we'll work
from there but let me show you the video
first because it is pretty interesting
it's called Logan Paul is my hero so you
would play
oh I love that song I know that song I
knew you would love it do they claim
this that'd be crazy right I feel like
you would though this is you this is you
and this is me
local Paul put me in one of his videos
yeah bro I like you a lot I'm gonna fly
you out to L.A
he's going out yeah well you're going to
Japan I'm going to Japan I don't know I
was gonna say you're in L.A already let
me come dude let me come with the crew
you're in L.A already so um actually
that's gonna be a good saving for me
right off the bat well we can go to
Japan instead I'd love to take you guys
on the sites I really know a lot of
stuff about it yeah anyway
[Music]
I want to make a song with you and then
make the dopest music video of 2017.
yeah because you know we need we need
some good PR for Ethan because some
people are saying like not everybody
loves Ethan Klein yeah statements
possible how is that even possible
exactly
so generous I think this is what we need
for your VR my yeah image Revival yeah
well just take a look and tell me if you
feel comfortable doing this okay so here
it is dopest videos first of all wait
before you play it it's a fact no
and so the answer is yeah the answer is
yes already well let me hear the song I
love this one
so pull up do me a favor pull up or pull
up the lyrics to Logan Paul's my hero
and then I want you to read it off but
use but say Ethan instead of Logan and
let's just see if you have that we have
that natural Rhythm together we can do
it right now
I can do that but the money will have to
be wired in first no well this is an
audition this is an audition well I
think my work speaks for himself uh
multi-platinum it's a fact that everyone
has a hero yeah and sometimes you're
tickled just the right way you gotta
make a dumbass song about it fact so
this is that dumbass song double fact
and guess what I'm feeling tickled
you come that's you come in
all right
this is where you come in Ethan Klein is
my hero mm-hmm
yeah this is where you come in you pick
line is my hero
look like I said as soon as the money
gets wired to my account
good luck on Buttercup or Sea Biscuit
that's a real offer good luck at the
tracks dummy have you ever watched Shark
Tank hey are you sure if you think for
too long I'm out you know what you're
thinking for too long I take it back
yeah I'm out hey Eli you make that
person [__] remember that person
[__] uh at the train station yeah I
could do it today
right by my manager
bring the next person out oh hang up
wait wait I think we could talk this
through guys please let's go to Japan
together as a family
who else wants to ask for money
please you got
dude that's what I'm saying it's like
it's always the same thing with him it's
just not
I'm reporting his account too yeah
report yeah for for
spamming and scamming I mean might as
well be unbelievable
annoying
while that was all going on I think I
saw somebody say that a bees thing
happened so I'll try and Rewind it and
here's Dan
rewinding Abe's weigh-in then you really
need to do this character he's getting a
little uh chaotic over here here's Dan
right now we need like a gift stop
saying here's Dan because then I have to
go back and switch over you don't have
to do that but then they won't know
right right right right right right
that's funny here's Dan check this out
hey
I'm just leaving it on your screen oh
God
apart
oh no the Scorpion share the footrest
just completely collapsed
yo this thing is not built to laugh no
it's just broken no it's not just kind
of like the last one
anyway take a look at this is what Dan's
looking right right now
I'm just leaving it on your screen we
need like a video or something of this
character at work it's like moving
that's it that's it typing that's it can
we get that
his name is Camille is this within your
power hamaji here let me too oh maybe
there's just kamaji working 10 hours
Loop hold on I got you
homaji I'm just gonna work
here we go kamaji working 10 hours
I don't know what's going on back there
we initially made this comparison with
Ian back uh
sent you a fan art you know what's crazy
that looks more like a band though
that's it it could just be damned it
could be either one of them
huh who's the real kamaji
It's gotta be damn
right here let me think some sponsors
well Dan does it worked that up
three things one congrats from the
enormity of both of your success two
you're 100 correct with the kids on the
crew trip thank you dude who's this
person Jay's music okay what the [__] up
Jay dude watch your mouth when we're
talking he sent us 50 dollars
what have you done
uh he says also there is a Japan at
Epcot okay which is the busiest trip of
all he says we can do Japan and epic oh
that is so wait what does that mean
Epcot is one of the parks at Disney
World and they have themes from all
around the world and they have Japan
don't get me started about this idea of
going to Disney World I don't know why
you're hating I'm hating because
we're finally gonna take time off from
being a parent
Disney World whatever I've never been to
Disney World okay let's go there with
the kids right when we go with the kids
we have bringing the kids who do you
think they are
well listen I I'm against the Disney
idea I am going to bend to the cruise
will for this one
but I am just I'm vetoing Japan because
I just know hold on that's not fair
we're gonna do presentations next week
okay you can't veto it before you start
in my presentation
all right uh Lotus says ten dollars
towards uh Sam's Coachella pass that's
very gracious
Kaden turns 21 who's Kaden
uh probably whoever 21. [__] you there
you go on yeah happy 21st birthday Ela
is my biggest inspiration I always get
compliments on Teddy fresh Ethan being
critical of the hateful manosphere
reminds me there are good men yes oh wow
H3 family forever
all right what is going on here Dan can
we watch this yeah are you ready
let's do it thank you
full screen that
wait did Dad okay let's do this
oh
that Dad repping the blue Corner dude
that's it that's a real team [__] is he
wearing it
that's a good question do we stop
high-fiving people they don't even know
who you are just it looks like he works
at Disney World right he works like at
the Haunted Mansion right passing out
like donuts
whatever bro I got the best in the house
it's great that's where Amy's gonna
stick it in your corpse
170 pounds hell yeah sorry I don't know
I mean he's the one that turned around
and dropped trowel like I'm just saying
when you're trying to say you're beating
someone up dropping trowel and bending
over exactly he's like yo come hit him
come rail me
with his name on it too
absolutely
174 pounds okay
[Applause]
right there
I was gonna say you look like a host of
a restaurant but now right it's so
[__] crazy
that's right I spent a lot of money on
this please don't make fun of it oh dad
seriously you gotta go the pathetic
route always deposit Dan let's get a
picture he he acts like so tough and
[__] and then the minute he gets a
little goofed on he goes oh I can't
believe you made fun of me that looks
like Matthew McConaughey Magic Mike
Matthew McConaughey was a Magic Mike
right I mean I've never seen I was just
surprised he was he would take that role
at me such a star
yeah
okay that was a star movie does he get
naked in it
he's wearing underwear and a vest
and uh
and an armband but do you see dick and
Magic Mike not that I remember awesome
howdy skills let's get some houses going
all right go ahead av's looking cool as
a cucumber up there man
[Music]
okay let's not touch that yeah that's
not funny it's a crime all right
everybody
for our next fight we have William
all right I don't know he's looking
pretty good
the the height
is right on yeah that is old as [__] and
Amy's been working his butt off yeah
baby I'm feeling good yeah so by the way
if you guys want to watch along with us
tomorrow we're having a watch party is
going to be so much fun
please join us members
uh for members we will be doing a watch
party tomorrow what time are we starting
uh I think we will begin streaming at 2
um the Creator Clash event starts at
three okay so we'll start about a half
hour before and like I've mentioned
before but in case you didn't uh see we
won't actually be showing the event you
need to get your own ticket to watch it
this is just a sort of watch Along Watch
along
yeah I mean we tried it last year and
yeah it was a disaster no no you're
confusing now tipped when we tried to
stream immediately got a [__] board
yeah I don't know last year we did the
same way where we just watched along
yeah and in the role of of a lifetime
but it's a very chill hangout where we
all just sit here and watch the show
we'll be getting crunk
yeah eating fried chicken yes Pizza I
was thinking on the way here I noticed
Popeyes is like really close yeah yeah
why don't we eat Popeyes is good because
I know that it was like our Top Choice
when we did the taste test you want
Popeyes tomorrow [__] Fried Chicken
Fried [__] chicken I can make that
happen Okay Popeyes let's go so yeah
members we love you we'll see you
tomorrow can't wait for that oh people
sorry 2 30 Pacific time our time yeah
PST
so um Okay cool so we got through all
that
um
maybe come on I'm excited he's gonna
dude he's gonna murder him I got the
feeling he's like he's been training his
ass off dad's all show he got there's no
substance right that man he went in the
ring his professional fight lasted like
five seconds that's the totality of his
professional experience a b went pretty
much the entire way it did so good I
remember we all felt like if they let
him go for longer [__] but they
called it earlier
learning about it more afterwards it
made sense but
he's gonna do well it's going to be a
good fight I know that for sure I'm I'm
very excited
I'm really been looking forward to it so
Abe make us proud you make us proud no
matter what he's already made it you've
already made us proud
and he got his study fresh out
oh yeah we made him a custom uh robe
like last year but I feel like this we
do it all here it's all sewn by our team
here in the office nice this is a teddy
fresh Couture
yeah it's pretty cool
so um okay so let's just talk I mean so
yeah bbtv paid us it happened yesterday
during leftovers I got a a text message
from our finance head of finance and she
said
I just want to let you know 620
000 just hit your bank from bbtv
now Oliver's texting me [__] he goes
your whole team's a bunch of amateurs
dude leave me alone bro
what
you'll die I thought he wanted to be one
of the crew he just was asking to join
the crew yeah and I was the only reason
that you even got on the [__] show
because I took pity on you you pathetic
[__] losers
yeah you guys are too easy to win over
well
I mean
when you're on the phone with him for 30
minutes just sobbing his [__] eyes
out you you see how much pity you have
for him yeah so uh no I I get it I'll I
what I do is I just mute my mic and put
on like Animal Planet or something
um
um so yeah bbtv paid us and there's been
some and I just can't believe it frankly
first of all I can't believe it either I
this is the last thing I expected yeah
to happen this fast too first of all I
just want to say thank you to bbtv for
doing the right thing obviously I was
very glad that
he got on the phone with us
it was a very professional call it was
all politics it was all politics but
listen it was all they did the right
thing in the end and that was good
that's true they did do the right thing
I the thing that shocked me I genuinely
thought they did not have that money me
too
I mean that's a lot of money to pay at
once yeah because they could you know we
lost it over a long period of time two
plus years
everyone there was people being like
dude you gotta look back and audit more
because they paid you way too fast I was
like I don't want to look under the hood
I'm just gonna take the dub you know
what I mean I'm not looking under the
hood I think they just don't know what
else is going on there I think if
anything they just realized this was a
losing battle to go I try to say that to
them like first nicely then then uh in
in a in a great conflict and then
finally uh you know it's like I tried to
do it I said I did the nice way I did it
the [__] way
and ultimately where did it get us
people need to listen to me more I know
I know things
people don't listen to me that's the
biggest problem in the world
you know I agree I think oh thank you
you do I do thanks
I think you get bad rap
a bit well thank you my own wife
you think I get a bad rep yeah thanks
sweetheart
you heard that even my my wife likes me
guys well it's like it's also it's
always stupid like if we'll have a drama
thing going on some kind of conflict
then the one video where Ethan talks
about it we'll make it on on Reddit
videos you know will be the you're
talking about the video I made about the
TV stuff so that's all for some people
that's all they see right and it's just
like so not the substance right of what
we do that's one element if somebody
does wrong to you you always will talk
about it and call it out and not let it
slide
you know what since you're saying that
I'm going to pull this up because we've
done made a a point of honoring our
um our new and Fallen fans and making a
whole discussion about it
because we've been in the whole like 10
000 Subs every month for like God I
don't know a year plus
yeah about a year and this month we're
at 1.5
000 Plus
oh
it's like you know what's funny um
it's like in a status uh it's like going
every time I check it's hovering around
like the same number it's up it's down
it's like a battle there's a war going
on yeah he's up no it's so it doesn't
move that much but it's interesting it's
interesting that it's like the uh you
know in Harry Potter moldovore his
Abracadabra versus Harry Potter's uh uh
Avante and their beams hit each other
and they push him back and forth that's
what's happening in our sub you're speed
running just like fumbling the
pronunciation on every word that was
awesome the thing is I don't have time
to just figure out how to say it right
and it will ruin the thing I mean you
know Abracadabra and Krav McGraw
vogelberg his arch nemesis Volga board
vocabort does Krav McGraw and Harry
Potter hits him with the abracadabra
so
so it's cool to see it's cool to see and
if this is your first time tuning in
today let's make some magic happen uh
hit subscribe button today
let's make Harry Potter winner
spread the word Harry Potter Harry
Potter mine is a good guy
output so what you're saying actually is
interesting so here's someone said I am
one of the new 74 subscribers
I'm a new newly turned H3 stand recent I
thought I'd get my perspective on the
new fan Outlook with peace and love of
course so they're picking it up right
away they're doing good I just recently
got into the podcast and I was part of
my daily routine it's something I look
forward to I can just sense genuine
kindness from Ethan that's it I'm like
the dolly Mama but without the
pedophilia wait
well that's what you might say I sense
General kindness from the Dalai Lama but
you can't because he just was like
sucked my tongue too I didn't know about
that you didn't know about to suck my
tongue
oh yeah the Dalai Lama really [__] up
Dalai Lama's canceled he's canceled
right at the Finish wait did that just
happen yeah like a few days ago oh yeah
Grandpa hold up
damn it you gotta see it because
everybody loved the Dalai Lama yeah
that's why I was like wait what are you
talking about
so close to the Finish Line yeah and
then he asked some little kid to suck
his tongue on stage in front but it was
so on stage and then I learned when I
was talking to Hassan about it he's like
yeah uh the Dalai Lama used to have like
5 000 little boy servants
okay and I was like oh he [__] he
[__] them oh my God all right let's
not I don't wanna no see the videos it's
kind of funny and a little disturbing
it's worth watching
if uh
the Spirited Away character can pull it
up please
well uh yeah somebody you usually pull
up that where is everybody
right now it's all just news reports as
I said a skeleton crew let me let me
look it up I'll say uh
I'll say uh suck my tongue
Dalai Lama
here it is here it is
the Dalai Lama oh stop see this is this
is I got you hold on one sec this is
everything I hate is when they do that
um
here's the video you wanted to watch
here's copyrighted music over at me
talking over it
Inside Edition the dolly llama
ask the little boy to suck his tongue
roll it roll it
all right thank you Cameron
so Dalai Lama calls up a minor okay well
so it kisses him on the lips yeah ask
for a tongue kiss I got it notice where
he takes the boy's hand
so people are trying to defend it they
say sticking out the tongue is like a
Tibetan greeting that's what I wonder
because
sucking the tongue is not part of that
creative
it'd all be dead of covet or something
by now there was just all passing
sucking tongue yeah
then I think we finally here also
thank you
feeling a little frisky today
stop it that's funny though Kid Rocks
okay it says Grandpa's feeling a little
frisky today
Dan just like stop it stop it
I love it here it is
foreign
[Laughter]
I hate it I hate it actually I hate it
so much that I need yeah that today it's
like that scene it's like that scene
there's like that scene from Star Wars
where he's like it was a Han Solo goes
where does where does it hurt he goes
here he goes here
here
here that's what the Dalai Lama does on
little boys
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's right okay this and I kind of
didn't mind not knowing it until today
yeah the Dalai Lama were all the move on
them every time I got reminded why I
don't watch the news yeah
I'm doing a current event show this is
my obligation this is where I get my
news
[__]
[__] hell
where were we oh yeah so this uh so they
says I recently got in the podcast part
of my daily routine I sense genuine
kindness from Ethan how that started
this whole
tangent it's pretty wild
the crew and the true the show is truly
a masterpiece however starting out
there's definitely a bunch of inside
jokes bits that a new viewer will not
understand that could cause them to
quickly lose interest well we know that
that's what we're working to remedy in
fact tomorrow or Sunday maybe you need a
rule where you like the first 30 minutes
keep it pretty like
this is our plan on Sunday we're putting
up a two hour lore video that has every
that floor moment ever itself it's so
good that's awesome uh before I only
heard this is what you were saying yeah
before I only heard of Ethan and H3 from
drama videos bashing him and his content
and for a while that was deciding factor
for me as to why I didn't want to watch
the podcast I just assumed he made
podcasts to hate on people that was it
that's part of it I mean it's not all of
it it's part of it but it's far from
being all of it no and also when you do
it it's not just to hate on somebody
just because you're like you woke up and
you decided I want to hate on this guy
today no you know thank you it's like
yeah somebody was being like a really
big [__] saying some I don't know
homophobic stuff and then you're calling
them out
so he says but I was so wrong unless
you're keemstar Ryan Kavanaugh who does
look like RV Weinstein thank you the
broadcasters filled with so much love
humor and all great Vibes so this is so
this is great you know I love that a new
forever fan so we love them
so they're out there they're the tide is
turning
welcome
um
yeah but a lot of people
what was that
what was that welcome to a new episode
bro did he slur his word welcome to a
new episode of the clown show oh the
clown I believe that's what he said yes
so
um
but because of my Feud with bbtv a lot
of people made videos about me yeah and
because I was so obviously in the right
people were forced to side with me
against their desires to just appease
their fan base who probably mostly hates
me
and there was some really funny examples
of this for example most critical uh uh
did it and by the way I watched this
whole thing he was very uh
he was very supportive
but I just find it funny that you can
you cannot defend me without putting a
disclaimer here
but yeah I see a lot of people don't
like Ethan and that's totally fine you
don't have to like everyone or anything
but you can recognize that a situation
extends far beyond just one person there
I saw a lot of people on Twitter they're
like yo don't talk about don't defend
him bro
he's like [__] I better I better make it
clear that I don't like it's not because
I like him
it's because he's right
it's crazy dude yeah I literally am like
that's why I'm that's yeah that's what
I'm talking about too I'm like a YouTube
Voldemort or something
yeah
Abracadabra abracadabra
went out the same thing that bbtv has
been taking all their Channel membership
revenue or at 30 of their Channel yeah
yeah yeah then there was a
this one is actually quite sweet almost
in a way and I wouldn't expect anything
else from our boy here
oh now I must defend Ethan Klein he's
one of the most difficult things I have
to do but in this case you know I think
as much as it might pain Ethan to defend
me on a fair use issue I would suspect
that he would oh please you know I would
come on and I wouldn't even and I
wouldn't even be like this is the worst
day of my life because I have to defend
according I probably would yeah you
definitely would have I'd probably be a
lot meaner than he was
absolutely right I 100 would look I'm
40. I'm tired I know man I know wait I
know it brother me too man we have a lot
in common I love that I'm not long for
this planet wow that's that now that
sucks that's just sad quartering
something funny we need to let somebody
know
maybe he wouldn't stop it come on of
course you know I would all right anyway
whatever but here's one
this one goes out uh
this one's kind of surprised me at it
and I will say
again that she was very nice and and she
was very supportive but this comment
just kind of surprised me like even in
Emily Baker friend of the show
everyone's like [__] Ethan bro don't
defend him and it's like a legal Channel
like this is her whole goddamn job is to
talk about lawsuits and stuff I know and
I've seen some of you in the chat not
everyone loves Ethan Klein I understand
that not everyone on this platform am I
like [__] a murderer I mean what did
I do is that that exercising is bad Ah
that's true you did say that I mean what
did I do to deserve this
you know
am I really that bad
[__]
like genuinely what did I do other than
be fat
every year
why am I still getting hey I don't like
that comparison
to talk about lawsuits where there is
somebody that people in the chat don't
um don't love everything they've ever
done everything they've ever said dude
I'm not like uh who's like the flash guy
like I'm not like a sexual Criminal
he's like yeah I know some of y'all
don't like draw uh Amber Heard
she I know she's [__] his bed and
like beat him up
yeah I know some of y'all don't like uh
R Kelly but I just have to cover this
case it is new what did I do grumpy
and brutal man
and I don't know at what point I'll stop
clarifying that but we talk about
um people accused of all kinds of things
what have I done yeah what did I do what
am I accused of that's so bad and we
talk about their legal rights and that's
what we're gonna do we're gonna talk
about their legal rights so she I don't
received the bad comments though in the
chat I don't either that's what's
interesting I was looking I only see
some people who say they don't know you
but then others know you and they're
saying they love you also so
so again it's like every time someone
acknowledges me and Emily's a friend I
like Emily you know
like let me just start this segment by
giving you a full dissertation on why
it's important to talk about this even
though we hate Ethan
she's acting like she's like reading Me
My Rights I just got arrested for some
heinous crime yo dude speaking of people
are rationally hating on you
[Music]
what do we got look at this I'm shocked
by this right now what okay I guess I
shouldn't speak too much because I'd
have to watch it but based off of the
comments and the title and the thumbnail
Abba and Preach Today released a video
titled Ethan Klein is embarrassing and
it's about
this [__] idiot no they are defending
sea bass wait what wait they're
defending Sebastian bruh Abba and
freezer they're like I mean they're like
a manosphere
yeah I don't know what happened they
were like kind of they weren't like
political and they were cool and then I
think they just fell down the meme hole
they I fell down the meme hole hard wait
wait wait wait I'm embarrassing yes I
just want to be left alone no and like
when you look at the comments watch that
they're saying like oh you saying that
he's insecure is really just telling on
yourself and like all this stuff is just
like what in what [__] Universe did
this guy come across looking like
anything but a total [__] [__] that
was like the most Flawless victory yeah
ever how did they make content out of
this dude well let's see let's watch a
bit of it I don't know I don't know I
didn't want to even want to get off
track but wow that's yeah I see the chat
saying yes they're covering for them
holy [__]
how [__] lose but this is part of the
the problem is they he somehow he's
going to spin this into I'm embarrassed
yeah wow that just shows you how
irrational it is because no one can
watch that no I think that that guy
looked good that's insane that's
absolutely why would you even want to
defend Sebastian
I don't know see that's part of the
problem it's just so sad it's almost
like I'll never be able to claw claw
ahead because for dudes like that it's
so it's so valuable for them to just lie
and I don't mean that that take is
almost unreal it's like what the hell
well apparently I don't think so though
I don't think this is like I think it's
just like
a cool thing for the edu kids do not
like you I don't think it's those guys
that video is probably is definitely
gonna get millions of views
it already has like 200 000 yeah
Jesus man
uh somebody said a big issue they've had
before is that they didn't watch their
video and dunked on them off the
thumbnail only
yeah I mean who cares who cares what are
you talking about well I don't care
their opinion doesn't matter they're
obviously [__] I don't so they got
mad at me for I mean okay fine I got mad
I got mad at you for uh for making fun
of fresh and fit too yeah I remember
even though they dunk on them all the
time as well so because for me it's like
the easy target it's like you put Ethan
Klein and that he's embarrassing and
that's boom that's a good content gold
oh that's that is sad actually it's like
I go out there and I get a dub that I
feel is like Universal dub
it's like when I talk to Bradley Martin
I talked to Bradley Martin I was like yo
this whole thing on Tick Tock about
weight about me hating exercises crazy
and then one one of his editors puts out
a video cuts it up so it sounds like I'm
while talking to Bradley Martin saying
exercise sucks right like they they
don't even care yeah what's actually
happening yeah
ah
that's upsetting actually I just want to
be left alone I just want to be left
alone
God damn
all right
people in the chat saying have you
considered that you're fat though
I have I mean yeah I take that I
consider that in all uh conversations I
have let me think about it hold on I
start every conversation with well I am
fat I do hold disbelief
kind of like how people talk about me
can you somebody watch that and find
like a time stamp I I gotta hear how
they possibly spin this [__] crazy I
want to hear how they talk about me
they talk about you I'm online
so far but right now they're saying that
pretty does not equal provocative and
they're thinking that you were arguing
that but you were just using offhand you
were like so if she dresses pretty she
can do it when she's with me but not
when she's by herself but it that you
weren't really making that argument you
were just that's why I said let's when I
watch it it's going to be [__] brain
dead again or into you those guys it's
like semantics
all right
apparently I'm embarrassing well I'm fat
all right so anyway uh let's see what
else we got here if there's any good
time Stamps though I'll check it out
sure so moving on
um
actually this was a really fun take I
saw on Tick Tock What hap I think love
found this one
this one's awesome dude
it's a banger this is okay you're gonna
like this what happens when you put 100
million women on birth control and they
urinate all the birth control hormones
and estrogen into the water all right
and then the power plants and the
filtration plants and the plants that
process and treat the water are known
not to treat
estrogen
or home hormones
whether it's testosterone or estrogen or
whatever all these hormones are so
I think there's a big
conspiracy as to why people are becoming
extremely effeminate so again
[Music]
so this this guy's thesis is the first
of all that somehow first of all birth
control is the enemy right we start with
birth control right we don't want women
to be empowered with their sexuality so
let's take then we go to
peeing it out
well my favorite is estrogen makes
people act uh famine act like a bunch of
ladies maybe is there lots of people
acting effeminate is that is that a
thing I don't know maybe people are
feeling more comfortable
he's like you know is that a bad thing
you don't really see Cowboys and rope
and steer no more I think it's all the
estrogen in the water why
yes so uh I'm I hate to blow this guy's
mind but
I did some research it turns out there's
more estrogen in an apple
really
than a glass of tap water so I don't
know but apples are pretty gay so I'm
careful about that yeah
um let's see
uh beans lentils chickpeas they're all
gay those have a lot those are the
estrogen in it more than tap water
whole grains gay whole grain oats barley
wheat brand uh those are gay yeah yeah I
don't know about you but man I had like
a I had me like a nice little
peanut butter and jelly sandwich with
some banana on it and I felt so gay
afterwards boy like I took a birth
control pill
fruits and vegetables apples carrots
pomegranates cranberries are all gay
super gay more yeah yeah and a glass of
water
yeah
and this might shock you almonds
pistachios and walnuts are all super gay
as well they'll make you super
effeminate because everything that's
healthy
those guys can stay away from that's why
we just eat meat yeah just uncooked
cracked meat
oh but this is good this is gonna blow
their mind coffee tea and red wine are
super gay those all have estrogen in it
more than a glass of tap water but
do you even pee out the when you pee
like what are they even talking about um
yeah no that is a thing sorry it is a
thing but it's like parts per billion
you know it's like a Beyond negligible
yeah when uh I looked it up and love
sent it the other day and uh
something like 90 of the estrogen in tap
water comes from um from agriculture so
it's in everything because it's in
everything yeah and I think it was like
it was like one percent or something of
It Came possibly from contamination from
birth control also he says that they
can't remove it from the water supply
but that's also not true
I just said well I think he was saying
they purposely don't like they're
purposely letting it is that really what
he meant yeah because he's like talking
all conspiracy like they're trying to
sisify us all and trying to Bimbo fire
us and I just I don't understand like
they never explain why
why does the government want us all to
be more effeminate you're a bunch of
[__] why what's the end game I just
don't get it the conspiracies though
ah yeah so that was a that was a great
one I really enjoyed that or estrogen or
whatever all these by the way these
dudes like they're not only not doctors
they're just like the dumbest person you
knew in high school they're like dumb as
a cardboard and they're coming out here
with like medical analysis of tap water
they can't even like control not looking
stupid you know he's saying it and it
looks so stupid as he's saying it it's
like dude this is this just stop yeah
this is the dude who uh in high school I
think I knew him he would like he's the
dude who will like puke in the bathroom
from taking too much like Vicodin or
something
yo dude the water supply is turning us
gay
it's great the Manos for your [__] is
such brain rot what happens when you put
100 million women on birth control and
they urinate all the birth control
hormones is that that's our music oh
yeah estrogen into the water
gee what happens I don't know maybe go
to a class yeah that's what that was the
thing I was like maybe go to school
there's actually people that can answer
that yeah like if you're really curious
about something go study it that's it
that's the best part why are you asking
this dumb guy that's doing like
he's like I just like to experience I
think you're asking the wrong people
dude ask her there's like chemists who
specialize in like water like sewage
water and water recycling like there
they'd be a great person to ask about
this science is gay
it's in the filtration plants and the
plants that process and treat the water
are known not to treat you know um you
seem so passionate about like the
filtration systems like go study
something yeah go do something with your
tiny little brain it is interesting uh
the topics that you've identified just
exercise it a little bit right
why is it that when I drink piss
I feel a little fruity
when I drink my homies piss why is it
that I feel a little effeminate
afterwards I'm gay
yeah these guys roll
so you said that they had the rage quit
because it was they were so annoyed by
me
just sent you a timestamp that's
interesting okay let's see let's see how
uh
oh the urban whatever the Evan preach
they couldn't handle it was you were
just you were bombing this interview so
hard
my wife you said that but that's the
thing that he doesn't we know that he
does that okay
that they haven't said it's the same bro
you're so
angry right now
all right
same [__] and that's what Ethan does
they're not gonna do anything more We're
not gonna find some new thing that
they're gonna say that they haven't said
it's the same [__] from the past that's
gonna do this oh he's gonna find a
little thing well you said my wife like
that's something Ethan that's not a
thing shut up and you know it you call
herself
I gotta know what the [__] he's talking
about yeah all right here here they
watch this whole chunk and you don't get
and you're you're being unfair and
disingenuous and you're making you're
making dude they're they're inclination
to need to defend Sebastian is
mind-blowing yeah no this is this is
crazy
I just wish that their fans would at
least go watch the interview because
like they're not going to yeah you're
doing out of your way hey not to
understand I'm trying to say well of
course
of course I'm gonna go from there Hey
listen you like that [__] hey there you
go I'm gonna go for the juggling it was
hotter maybe not if I was hotter
she wouldn't feel the no matter if she
took care of it yeah yeah yeah if it has
to be hotter okay if I was skinny and I
had it six packs I saw you if she saw
you and you're like wow he really cares
and respects himself and I like his
attention and I don't need to go out
there and look for attention so they're
talking about okay he doesn't think that
you are women significant others should
post themselves with like cleavage and
stuff because I'm looking for attention
yeah yeah because you want to cheat on
me apparently that's right don't you see
you're insecure yeah because I know it's
not insecure yes it is you are insecure
dude
okay are you specifically talking about
how he doesn't want
his girlfriend he would never allow his
girlfriend to you know post pictures of
herself
so where and he thinks that she's fine
if she wants to right they everybody
forgets that that's part of the argument
it's not your girlfriend has to do this
it's would you be okay with it if your
girlfriend
Genesis for this was he put out a video
on Tick Tock like uh
something about like how women should
dress yeah
so let's see the genius take here yeah
yeah I'm not gonna lie I think that [__]
hurt yeah of course it did yeah if she
wanted you there's no contact
if she wanted to post a picture and I
said look I don't I'm not comfortable I
don't like it and she did it anyway
that's fine she can do it anyway and
then we I would just be like hey this is
the way they cut this is insane they
just make it look like I'm bullying him
he's like listen I it's just my opinion
it's just my preference and I'm like
whoa you know
that's crazy you're insecure it's fun
dude these guys are pieces of [__] yeah
no they suck the boundary of the
relationship this brings the the
sanctity of the intimate relationship I
want to have with my wife the heart of
the conversation is completely removed
I'm gonna just split here
different types of girls who have
different ideas of what they want to do
like just don't seek out a girl who's
who wants to post [__] like that don't
condemn girls who do like what the [__]
just let them do what they want let your
girlfriend do what she wants and if you
have a problem with her specifically
talk to her about it his point was that
women should not do this and so I'm
probing his logical fallacies they're
cutting out the whole context the heart
of the conversation there's such [__]
douches that's that's just lame like if
you guys actually want to engage with my
points don't be like [__] cowards and
cut out the actual heart of the
conversation we didn't watch the whole
video I don't know well I'm just
watching this clip you know what I mean
they cut out the context you want to see
what they're watching before here I
don't really understand Keith is framing
this thing is crazy I don't think that
if I have a girlfriend she should go she
should have a desire to go out there and
even seek the attention from other men
because the attention she gets from me
is enough
this guy thinks he knows how every
single woman thinks and what she does
and why she does it so if I dress nice
they think that I do it because I want
other men's attention
that's not what I want you don't know
what I want you don't know me
that is not how it works I don't care if
other men give me attention I don't
actually do it for that so you guys
don't know [__] and I post Instagram I
post Instagram photos most of my
audience is women I don't even post it
for guys you guys don't know [__] if you
feel cleavage for me I posted foreign
I'm like hell yeah it's a gift it is I
mean that's what it is it's for my
ladies out there literally we all
girlies hold on I I actually it's just
it's so upsetting to hear them talk
about women like some kind of object
like you guys don't know me and thank
God you don't I don't want anything to
do with you but you don't know me you
can't talk about this scenario of me
posting on Instagram or me going out
dressing nice and what it means for
Ethan like you guys don't know [__]
you know what I mean what are you even
talking about I mean yeah what is this
imaginary scenario yeah that I'm going
now to seek out attention of other men
but I don't know if I'm going out I'm
going to a nice restaurant to get some
like top top of the line food you know
I'm going for all kinds of stuff I'm
going to buy some Top Line designer
clothing you know and I'll dress nice
for that and I don't even look at you
and your attention can go right into the
trash can
I don't I don't even know if that's what
they're trying to say if it's almost
like they setting up a straw man without
any contacts and being like well look
how Ethan like Ethan said I will
actually I want to watch this what
Sebastian was saying is that when no
it's the backstage [__] dead wrong
thing then a photo it's to seek out mail
attention yes that's 100 his point and
that's what I'm talking about if if
these guys are siding with him let me
hear what they say because I don't know
if they're if they shouldn't okay and so
well to me it seems like this whole part
is about the Instagram thing
so let's just stay on the topic of of
provocative let's watch it watch it all
right we're going in here I don't want
them being like they won't even watch
the whole thing
and not edit it up like they did you
guys you didn't even watch the video all
right let's watch this taste of [__] by
the way Abba and preach you cowards you
losers when you make a video about this
which I know you will titled Ethan
client's mat or whatever include this
a link to the full interview and
encourage your audience to go watch that
full interview
go tell them go watch that full
interview where Ethan's so embarrassing
and then come back and tell me how
embarrassing Ethan is because I know and
we'll play this whole thing or you're
just the biggest coward in the world
I am sure that if any one of your fans
watch that whole interview they will
realize
what a disingenuous piece of [__] you're
being right now
so that's it you know
just do that
girls can't wear so let's see let's take
a look at this
yeah I'm gonna speed it up because let's
be real
it's not that [__] interesting
but now I just now I'm here so I gotta
do it yeah we're committed well depends
I mean I guess that's too fast
slow it down a little bit
obviously but if she's dressed
provocatively and I'm not with her
there's absolutely no reason why
you know what I can't do it like this
sorry
we're gonna have to maybe one two five
that's another thing you should only
care about my attention oh here's the
music okay when you're with me but if
you're not with me you need to not look
pretty that's not what you said I like
that well let's [__] clarify dude let
him answer we're working out
we're having a long conversation dude we
we come to an understanding of what I
mean
like
he did say that though he said
don't dress like that if you're not
going out with me I say pretty in the
sense that like that I think that
like I sh whatever let's just see what
they say I mean watch it's completely
looking pretty with dressing
provocatively there's plenty of women
who look very pretty and don't dress
incredibly provocatively you can look
pretty in a dress okay it was awesome
yeah no [__] we know
we know dressing provocative yeah okay
if you didn't like the exact word I used
that's fine but like uh
let's not pretend that it's about
something else you dumb ass also you're
clearly not saying that sexy is the only
version of pretty which they kind of
alluded to a bit
um you're just saying that she feels
pretty I don't even think you're saying
she looks well we've established earlier
that way yeah we established earlier in
this conversation I think that women
dress nice to so that and look nice and
sometimes what he thinks is too sexy to
feel good about themselves it's not
about trying to appeal to other men
it was pretty in a T-shirt and some
pants you look pretty in a lot of
different outfits okay yeah no [__] no
[__] dumb [__] you're not re you're
not doing rocket science this is
literally what I said like they cut out
me saying that and be like look at an
idiot he says you guys are such cowards
like at least and like at least engage
with the conversation in an honest way
her thong to look pretty you don't have
to be provocative too pretty now what
provocative is me very personal person
but it's not the same thing no which is
funny because in a sense they're trying
to defend him but that is almost what he
is saying he's saying you cannot dress
like
[__] okay wrong
my stance is you shouldn't dress
provocatively unless you're with me
what's provocative this is what we're
talking about his his this is what we're
talking about you didn't say provocative
is pretty or not or whatever it's
because he's saying specifically you
cannot dress provocatively if you're not
with me and that is controlling and that
is going back a thousand years right I
will dress however I want if I'm with
you or without you
nobody will tell me how to dress that is
the point but this is what we're talking
about the thing that they're saying he's
saying is you can dress that way with me
but not not without me so why is that
why is why do you hold that belief it's
not oh I don't want you to dress this
way it makes me uncomfortable it's you
can dress this way with me but not with
other people
Abba and reach [__] god dude there it
is yeah
showing a ton of cleavage or wearing as
little clothing as possible wearing
political clothing is possible okay so
it's cool when they're with you because
but if they go out looking like that
it's not okay and I mean no I would say
even okay but that's literally what you
said in the video Even when there was me
I wouldn't want them to do that in
public okay
okay
what's the problem well it's just it's a
little insecure listen people know dude
let's see what they say but based off
the kind of things that they wear
they're going to get a different
reception from people yeah if I'm with a
woman yeah and she's out here dressed
like she's going to Cancun tomorrow I
don't feel a little bit like that she is
off not because it makes me like you're
inside you're you're 100 insecure then
yeah you can't handle it dude
you're [__] out of yourself
completely sorry it does
the things that they wear they're gonna
get a different reception from people
yeah if I'm with a woman and she's out
here dressed like she's going to Cancun
tomorrow I'm gonna feel a little bit
like that she is off yeah yep that's
your problem
look it's your preference if you don't
want to be with a girl who's comfortable
doing that right but the but the
underlying emotion which was try I was
trying to coax out with Sebastian is
that what is that feeling of feeling off
mm-hmm you're uncomfortable with other
dudes looking at her
because a lot of girls
a lot of girls will be doing
her if you guys understand like we like
I'll do my nails you know who's gonna
comment on it all the girls in the
office not the guys the guys don't give
a [__] let's just saying I don't do it
for you they got everything that we do
is about men men do the same thing they
go to the gym and they get all jacked
it's like yeah bro let's [__] go show
me your [__] gains dude like the
women don't care about that [__]
not because it makes me uncomfortable I
just think it's unsightly to be that
desperate for attention yeah I think
it's gonna be coming me partially it's
the same thing with women posing clear
straps everything I don't give a [__] if
women want to do that but if we together
and you post on Thursday who are you
trying again it's like I really need to
see the outfit we're talking about
because I feel like their definition or
at least Sebastian's definition of
provocative is not really provocative
who's attention you trying to Garner if
you're in a committed relationship with
somebody and you constantly gonna try to
post things to get random attention from
random people I'm like why am I
why are you thirsting for other people's
validation like that this is the same
thing for dudes again that wasn't even
the argument it was he said you can
dress that way with me but not with
other people it wasn't
why are you desperate for attention and
you always dress like this you it was
I'm okay when you're dressed like this
with me but not with other people it's
the controlling that's the insecure part
if you're in a relationship and you're
casually constantly posting thirst traps
to get attention from ladies to get them
in your comments like oh that's not what
that's not even what we're talking about
yeah I didn't say your girl's constantly
posting thirst traps I wouldn't be mad
if a girl feels some type of way it is a
little it's a it's a preference well no
it's a perfect difference well in this
video because you're kind of walking it
back so we can move on but in this video
you say dress sexy when you're with me
but not when you're not with me women
can dress sexy and not provocatively you
can dress sexy and can we play together
without showing like because in fact at
this point we're so removed from yeah
where the conversation started can we
show what he said yeah they didn't I
don't know I don't think they showed the
whole thing do you remember that Tick
Tock that he put out because that's why
you have yeah that's what triggers yeah
somebody can grab that
it's not insecurity either it's it's not
insecurity it's just I don't want I
don't like that I don't want it like
let's follow this no it's not because
you're you're basically would you want
your wife out there okay pulling all
your wife out there dress like a hoe
see like what does that mean like a hoe
like provocative uh I mean guys come on
well the definition of a hoe I guess is
I'm not quite sure what that means
but you're gonna answer my question
would you would you want her out there
dressing or wearing as minimal clothing
as possible out in a club
what I want my well hold on hold on hold
on no answer the question okay well let
me show you this yesterday okay well
hold on I don't know what he means I
need to know what does dressing like a
home mean to him
wife dressed like a hoe here because I
just want to get your she posted this to
someone would you go out to dinner with
your wife dressed like that of course
you wouldn't go like that I mean what
that's not what he asked actually wait
wait why not
no no this is actually really good would
you want to go with your wife to Dinner
dress like that why no because
inappropriate why again the point is
that he said with me
and not with other people
that's so stupid
inappropriate because it's too [__]
much we all get that we all understand
this like I would not kick it with a
girl who got [__] long ass Nails you
know them [__] saber tooth you guys
can be into it whether we like it or not
clothing says somebody a woman wouldn't
want to hang with a dude who constantly
sings his pants and got his boxers and
his ass cheeks hanging out pause you
wouldn't want to take him out to many
dinners you going to a family fun shirt
or whatever you probably don't want your
boyfriend showing up in a tank top hits
or shorts with his [__] biceps
bolstering out when it's like a more
modest family or a traditional family
you'll be like please put on the
appropriate outfit because
that's not the conversation this is not
why we had the guy on the show this is
like not this is the straw man we had
the guy on the show because he had a
tweet for example that said you're right
your ideal wife should have no attitude
you know that that's why we have him on
the show pleasure this guy's at this
point are so removed from why the
conversation even started yeah talking
about somebody dressing for a family the
classics like what the [__] everyone has
their yeah I know every when we meet
with my family everybody sits down in a
bikini
you guys are nuts
well they're they're just dishonest it's
just a bad faith analysis
this video has the music on it but they
subtitled it
okay so I'll mute it yeah
so here I'll just have to read it over
so it goes
what if a girl can cannot wear
what my girl cannot wear fashion is so
broad hold on let me start over
if you're dating a girl there's a thing
she cannot wear well depends I mean
fashion is so Broad
so I'll have to see but if she dressed
provocatively and I'm not with her
there's absolutely no reason why she
should be dressed that way for attention
if I'm not there go out with her that's
another thing then it's like you should
only care about my attention if you're
my wife there should be no other
attention from a man you should care
about other than mine
so again that's deeply insecure and
wonderful pretty [__] different than
whatever the [__] I don't know if that's
preacher Abba or whatever the [__] reach
reach yeah reach is really reaching like
like
they're just pandering to their fans who
don't like me because I'm fat you know
it's so stupid it's pathetic okay for
you no no it's not inappropriate you're
insecure you know like you're insecure
we we want to do this nobody was talking
it's about going out to dinner with your
family and I didn't call them insecure
because he won't go to dinner with his
wife in a bikini
is silly is so far away from reality at
that point also in that interview you
clearly say well I mean Ela wouldn't
wear that to dinner but oh yeah because
he tried to use that in his argument and
you were like I mean that's a silly
argument
I was simply trying to understand if you
thought you were dressed like a hoe so
that I could get a read on what is
definition of hoe was super weird
liberal thing where we say uh women got
their titties popping out of their shirt
it doesn't mean it not inherently but we
do understand that what you choose to
wear how much you choose to reveal says
something I agree I mean what the [__] I
don't when did I ever disagree with that
some kind of reaction right that's why
we have so much money average
that's why we have so much money
advertising in terms of what is it or
sexy and who we choose to hire okay so
you're saying sex sells yeah everybody
knows that I gotta skip forward
did we go into marketing now what have
you been talking about I'm not cool I
don't know who you're talking to but I
know it's not me yeah I mean that's cool
dude I appreciate all that information
but uh got nothing to do with me the one
on the left they're so heated by the end
he just he says he's done yeah no it's
it's yeah is he the coconuts and
Barbados of this Duo because he hasn't
really said [__] and he just kind of
shaking his head the whole time coconuts
in Barbara
Andy says more it seemed like okay
yeah no imaginary Ethan is really shitty
he's super annoying I [__] hate all
of his takes I'm right there with you
guys
seems what that [__] means so he doesn't
want his partner indeed in that kind of
behavior yeah that's fine
but do you know why she's posting I mean
that's that's you and your watch your
relationship
I'm trying to understand your point
would you do you think she's dressed
like a hoe right now and you can say yes
it's fine
yeah I wouldn't want her posting I
wouldn't want my girlfriend posting
pictures because that's a preference
from insecurity right yeah because it
makes you feel insecure even that's not
an argument you can't just repeat the
same thing and then think it's gonna be
true if you keep saying foreign
a preference from insecurity yeah sorry
it is it is an argument actually and you
can just say no but you're wrong so okay
the attention first of all it's not like
she's she's not dressed like a porn star
okay she's wearing less than a bikini
top or more than what a bikini top would
show it's just it's like you're just
you're wearing clothing it's normal
clothing like sports and bra and boy
shorts so if that so if if a post that
mild
gets you upset
you're deeply insecure why because the
mint there's people looking at it
their attention makes you uncomfortable
I mean it's pretty obvious right
their attention
makes you threatened makes you feel some
type of way
what are they saying about it let me see
how does it make you feel
I don't like the the hold on let's
how the women is how that girl is
portraying herself like how she's
basically advertising and like saying
like look how nice my body looks for the
entire world to see for the entire
public to see I don't like that I want
to just save that for me why don't you
like what I like but I want other people
singing it's mine are you not mine it's
yours it's yours it's my wife I don't
want everyone to see my wife
they say that I'm not making an argument
but him stopping his argument at She's
mine is not an argument you gotta unpack
that you can't quote if your partner
comes to you and is like yo and they
feel like the insecure about the thing
you have to
what did I do to make her feelings
insecure you also have to ask a question
to yourself maybe it's something that
you did maybe that person has reason to
think certain things so it's not always
the person okay so now it's this big
hypothetical situation this is about you
bro they got nothing to me I don't know
what issues you have with your mom or
your current significant other but
listen it's got I don't know who you're
talking to nothing to do with this I got
nothing hey I don't know nothing about
nobody
he's like sometimes they did other
things
you know well sometimes they flirt with
your best friend and that you think is
too far I'm like Jesus bro okay listen
I'm just a bartender I don't you know
what I mean I'm not paid for this
that's always a person
feeling insecure out of the blue right
you have
bro what are you saying but that's not
so stupid she's like you're building a
whole story yeah we're not talking about
whoever this hypothetical person is
we're talking about Sebastian
you showed him my photo and he said he
would not be okay with it
yeah and that's what the conversation is
that's it
what signals am I putting out there that
makes that person think like that yeah
are you out there just being incredibly
physical what made me think like that
like post is that what he's saying what
made me think like I want to post this
I'll tell you what I don't know what
he's trying to say I had two kids and I
did all that with my own buddy and I'm
exercising and I'm looking hot [__] yeah
and that's why I wanted to that's what I
was thinking I wasn't thinking about you
guys and I wasn't thinking about the
other guy you look great and I wasn't
thinking about any guys except my
husband okay and it has nothing to do
with my post
but I don't I don't even know what he's
trying to say I think that's because
he's saying if he was in the
relationship with me he would be
thinking what is causing her to want to
is that really what he said that's what
he's saying let me go back yeah it's
crazy your partner comes at least that's
how I understand it he feels like the
insecure about the thing you have to
what did I do to make her feelings
insecure what did I do to make her
feelings maybe it's something that she
I don't even really follow he's saying
that the girl is only posting that
because you're saying he needs
validation I'm thinking what did I do to
make her feel like wait is that really
what he's saying yeah like he's seeking
it from someone else okay wait so these
guys are not even these aren't serious
people yeah this is room temp IQ [__]
okay hold on hold on
a relationship you can't post it's your
partner comes in a relationship there's
certain things you can't post okay so
okay I agree I don't want ELO posting a
picture of her [__] on uh Instagram
right me neither but that's I was trying
to gauge where his definition of hoe is
right he thought Ela was dressed too
provocatively
that is [__] ridiculous
so okay there's certain things you can't
post
yes and not hers in relationships you
can't post if your partner comes to you
and like yo and they feel like the
insecurement thing you have to
what did I do to make her feelings
insecure y'all so so I have to ask
myself
yo what am I doing that's making her
want to hoe out on Instagram
let's keep listening I have to ask a
question to yourself maybe it's
something that you did maybe that person
has reason to think certain things so
it's not always a person when someone
says something it's not so it's always a
person the student is not even he's
hardly intelligible this man is just
like like the fact that they left in
this like incoherent rambling is crazy
he is the coconut surprise are you a
coconut dude what the hell like people
actually watch this and they're like
uh-huh it's like listening to boomhower
come on
Instagram post and Instagram man come on
man talk about insecure everyone's like
what man you want to yeah come on get
that Instagram man something you can't
post man make me insecure ask me why I
make myself gotta ask her man what's
going on
over there
let me keep hearing this feeling
insecure out of the blue right you have
to understand all right if that person
thinks like okay he started over he goes
wait wait wait let me start over wait
wait wait okay hold on hold on hold on
try that again hold on yeah try that
again I'm secure out of the blue right
you have to understand
I love that wait wait wait hold on
something it's not so always a person
feeling insecure out of the blue right
you have to understand omi's not even
listening he's just like he's like this
dude's just on his [__] again
he's he's got to be the one that edits
these otherwise this [__] would never
make the cut yeah
like that
what signal am I putting out there that
makes that person think like that yeah
are you out there just being incredibly
physically affectionate with every woman
you've seen oh my partner's insecure
it's like you're also doing something
that's incredibly weird yeah yeah I
don't know what you guys are talking
about wow I think they totally like
botched the whole conversation because
they took using and secure and then
about Sebastian but then they totally
mixed the word insecure into everything
and now they're like I'm insecure
exactly before they go they heard me say
insecure and then they started trauma
dumping
they're like listen guys I know it's
hard being a man it's hard motions are
really complicated it's very difficult
oh my God you know I didn't know we were
watching bot
oh [__] it's so this is kind of part of
their conservative Griff that makes it
so [__] easy to make content it's
awesome caught my girl sitting on
another man's lap you're insecure what
again nobody was talking about that
man's laughing so you're insecure like
how did we get here
yeah dude nobody was talking about
standing on somebody's lap the thing is
they haven't accused me of anything that
I don't
well like I pretty much fully agree with
everything they've said that's right the
problem is I never said any of that and
so of course it's easy to win an
argument with somebody that's not
actually even making that argument yeah
it's literally called that's what a
straw man argument is literally right
I think you're gonna make it appropriate
oh well you walk in and your girls
sucking another dude's dick insecure I
mean come on
you're telling me you walking in on your
wife sucking another man's dick wouldn't
make you feel insecure you got me there
bro
you [__] you got me
you guys are dumb asses
you guys are such dumbasses just tell
when you make a video
prove to me that you're not cowards and
tell your audience go watch the whole
interview
go watch the whole interview
show me how courageous you guys are
and then let's see what they think when
they watch the whole thing dumbasses
losers
[__] manosphere loser ass
pandering dumbasses coconuts and
Barbados
made is Wednesday bro you know you guys
it's like [__] this isn't like a therapy
couch I mean what the [__]
if someone's catching you like let's say
I got my girl if I catch my girl sitting
on a whole man's lap and I'm like yo
yeah that's in the realm
now you're just next I'm gonna say
you're just cool with cheating yeah
what the [__] an irrelevant Gaslight
dude you guys are like in outer space
from where this conversation started I
don't think he knows what that means
then that
then that someone that's
you if I catch my girl sitting on a
whole man's lap and I'm like yo hold
this dude you're insecure no nope you're
insecure bro
why would I make that argument
it's so far from what I even said it's
incredible they take their audience on
this ride so far from away from reality
and now we're in this space where we can
say anything and that's kind of one of
the things that's been consistent about
like my haters quote unquote
they can they've made me into such a
boogeyman they can pretty much accuse me
of saying anything and Their audience
will believe it somehow it's like yeah
no dude it's insecure if you're [__]
if you walk in on your woman getting
like trained by 20 guys
that's what Ethan said she's gaslighting
you from the realm of gaslighting yay
whether it be the clothes whether he's
sitting on someone's lap whether it be
like doing extra long hugs for specific
women that like I don't know I just
think there's basic messaging and you
guys want it there is so much
he's like listen there is so much more
about those long hugs with specific
people
what yeah sorry you got cheated on 22.
that is oddly specific you walk on it
your girl giving a hug to your homie way
too long that's gaslighting if you walk
in on that same girl with your best
friend homie who's named you know uh
Mikey
when you were 19
then that made you feel insecure you see
Ethan
you know and then one and then if you
try to hook up with her and then you're
you're flossing you can't get it up oh
what so that's my fault
and then what she it gets awkward and
she's asked me why can't I get it up so
Ethan what's your point
you say it does okay I guess I guess
actually the gestures don't mean
anything anymore let's play Raven his
lungs are we provide can we say
anything's provocative no I'm actually
curious that's my point that's the point
I was trying to clarify with your boy
Sebastian who says that uh
women cannot dress provocative
provocatively at all right so that was
what I was trying to uh ascertain as
these Geniuses found out on their own
he's provocative that it's elicit a
reaction the whole point okay
everybody's everybody goes no no no no
no you're you're
you're supporting Ethan right now you're
missing the point
able to wear whatever that happened
because no no no
actually the gestures don't mean
anything anymore what's the point of
laundry Raven is lingerie can we say
anything's provocative no I'm actually
curious can we say anything is
provocative that it's illicit a reaction
the whole point okay everybody
everybody's able to wear whatever the
hell they want and not being asked
anything and it doesn't have any effect
on people no no it shouldn't okay and so
well to me I don't want to control I
want my my wife Ila to be as powerful
and confident as she wants to be I'm not
threatened if it makes you feel
confident and Powerful to post search
traps on social media that's not a
thirst strap dude again it's not it's
just not a third strap
if you want to call it that sure or
whatever yeah it doesn't meet my
definition of a thirst trap like not at
all see how we can okay I can see how we
can if you need internet validation for
you to feel powerful and confident in my
opinion that's not much power and
confidence my personal beat if you have
to Post online and have a bunch of
strangers tell you you're amazing for
you to feel power and confident I don't
know to me that seems a little bit okay
your whole video is to make you feel
confident
to me your whole video is a little sus
yeah I agree you didn't even try it well
they did the argument again to the point
of the post was to show that uh how far
you've come after two pregnancies you
know but it's not a thirst trap I mean
come on
give me a [__] break
if she wants to go out and dress sexy
and look good you're against that
yes yes yes I'm against her dressing
provocatively she can look nice women
putting on makeup and dressing sexy and
going out it makes them feel powerful it
makes them feel good you're going back
to sexy and beautiful he said
provocative not one have you said well
you literally just were like what is
provide what is provocative
these guys are stupid
willingly provocative
you're not the same thing yeah
this is what makes them slimy the dude's
explaining himself I think you believe
himself with that no he's just an idiot
dude Sebastian believes in himself you
don't listen to him bro
Sebastian is awesome dude you guys need
to really listen to him
he's like convinced like his side of the
aisle is always right so he just
constantly talks like it and anyone else
they're insecure they're afraid or
whatever it's like no sometimes I just
think it's disrespectful that's it I'm
in a committed relationship with you
there's a certain amount of respect that
we have to have I mean I I they're
basically just having an argument with
themselves so just go talk to your
therapist I don't see any point to
finish this yeah me neither yeah I mean
ultimately I summarize it by them
completely not engaging with my real
arguments and totally missing the point
yeah oh the Vets are here what the f Oh
I thought they were going to meet us at
our house and it was going to be too
late oh okay we worked it out Shredder's
getting fluids yeah nice
or Shredder here no fluids
I really need to pee go ahead but
yeah dude when you make your videos just
say
Ethan says if you guys watch the whole
thing
you will not see it in the same way
so here's our challenge
thank you you guys saw you guys are
lamos dude straight up [__] lamos
thank you
all right weirdo bro weirdo bro
dogs are so [__] dumb
and so are humans
[Music]
Jesus the Bulldogs can't swim right
that's a thing
[Music]
you don't get get risky your dog oh my
God what the [__] this video I'm this is
this is really upsetting okay the dog
the dog's fine no let's start out there
[__] up he's so dense he just keeps
sinking why are they not helping their
[__] dog
what kind of pool is this it's just like
a death trap it literally looks like
they don't want to get wet but their dog
is absolutely dying it's great it is
literally dying and you don't want to
get your pants wet yeah pick it up this
man is putting a stick in like what are
you trying to grab you on grab on he's
on a marshmallow
oh no it's not a stick it's just a
[__] thing
[Music]
Jesus Christ bro
[__]
oh my god dude you all can't have that
pool we gotta empty that pool yeah time
to drain it you're stupid because it's
it's dangerous to both of you guys
it's like here's the shallow end and
here's the dying we just go to die on
this end
oh my God the fact that Bulldog goes
right back in is so [__] funny
like it wasn't traumatic enough for him
Donnie yeah uh let's see what else we
got oh well let's get to the main story
here which is sunny V2 here
those guys are so upsetting man so
upsetting it's like if you guys are
gonna make me be the bad guy at least
[__] argue with what I said just not
it's just it's so tiring man
it's like easy dubs so easy to be a
grifter conservative
[__]
okay
so
let's talk about this um
Mr Beast Chris stuff
oh Mr Beast guy Switching gears a little
bit here
so Chris from Mr Beast
you guys probably all watch Mr B so you
know him
he is this guy
before he started transitioning
just so you recognize him he was this
guy
and now he's started doing recently I
guess two months ago he started uh
hormone replacement treatment
he's non-binary so he says uh he any
pronouns fine before you try to [__]
cancel me
and uh now he is uh
he's not gender non-specific he says
and so uh this has been playing out
slowly on Mr BEAST's videos and people
have started to notice it
and
you know this is like height of trans uh
hysteria right now yeah
so you can see these kind of posts like
this people go Mr BEAST's friend Chris
says near word for word what a
demon-possessed man told Jesus Christ
we are like a legion we are one we are
many watch this [__] this man here's
evidence that Chris is a demon
and G and Jimmy's Jesus apparently
133 million subscribers I think we're on
141 now that's cool we get it you gain a
lot of subscribers so fast you're so
popular and so famous or it is to you or
I mean in a way it is to me I am Mr
beasts we are like a legion we are one
we are many is it not like the guy Fox
movie yeah it's like it's like in common
vernacular it's like a cultural thing
everybody
you know what I'm saying what was that
the [__] V for Vendetta I mean it's
in a million things that's a very common
expression uh very quotable so he's a
demon according to this person and
there's lots of stuff like this I mean
this video that this person posted has
four million views and 10 000 likes
so there's a active group of people who
are like yes
that's demonic they dug up old videos of
Chris
uh this is I guess their slam dunk all
right against him
they digging up this video of them like
from 10 years ago making
I would say mildly transphobic jokes but
at the time people were probably still
dropping f-bombs like it was
you know
nothing so here here this is them trying
to own uh Mr Beast and Chris let me see
if they've updated the gender list
making the fun they have 63 genders up
there but they can't have my gender
bro what are you doing
bro did you just assume my gender
I'm sorry I didn't mean to misgender you
I mean it's like edgy 14 year old comedy
that's what they are so old yeah it's so
old
they're like see bro you once made a
video about being trans so therefore you
[__] are faking it like I don't know
what their thesis is
uh just that the the old Chris would
bully the new Chris I was always that
I've seen that comment a lot old Chris
with bully nudes by the way old Chris
wasn't a bully he wasn't like a dick he
wasn't bullying anyone and also knew
Chris is a grown adult and the same
person millionaire and actually the same
person yeah right the same person and
probably wouldn't be bullied by like a
14 year old
yo this 14 year old would have [__]
hated her
absolutely
teen
is Shredder done he did the the fluids
[Applause]
thank you so much
you did so good let me just we just got
a comfort ready yeah
they're all done
Alfredo you're a good boy too but you
didn't just get fluids
[Music]
I'm so confused about Shredder's
condition yeah
he looks totally fine he's like better
than ever
yet his blood levels keep getting worse
he's like near total kidney failure
now when you have kidney failure you're
supposed to be
he's supposed to be lethargic which is
nauseous he's not
he's not only is he has more energy than
ever
he's in a great mood
he's eating more than ever we're not
even giving him an appetite stimulant
he's like eating a lot yeah and
apparently he's like
a month away from Total kidney failure
wow it's so bizarre it doesn't make any
sense I don't [__] get it so
yesterday we did this test for Addison's
disease now I don't know that the doctor
and the specialist both said they don't
think it's a necessary test but I said I
just want to be sure but I don't know if
there's something else going on because
this does not make any [__] sense to
me how is my dog dying he's like better
than ever so dude it's been this whole
situation has just been like
such a constant mind [__] for me
emotional roller coaster
so I decided we're going to get him
fluids every day for a week just to keep
him like super hydrated and see
see how that affects him like I remember
when he was super sick his breath was
like really stinky and now his breath is
like totally fine
I don't get it man
I just don't understand it
and my expectations are all over the
place which stresses me out even more
because like yeah one day I'm like maybe
maybe maybe he'll recover and then the
next day he's like he's gonna die in a
month
the roller coaster is crazy yeah
you're such a hellophobe get out
I sexually identify as an attack
helicopter ever since I was a boy I
dreamed of soaring over the oil fields
dropping hot sticky loads on disgusting
foreigners
people say to me that a person being a
helicopter is impossible I'm having a
plastic surgeon install rotary blades 30
millimeter cannons and AMG 114 Hellfire
missiles on my body from now on I want
you guys to call me Apache and respect
my right to kill all right so you got
the idea yeah so again it's just cringy
2013 humor yeah
[__] it Chris and Mr Beast deleted video
thread nice try nobody cares dude
yeah I mean attack helicopter was like a
dumb Reddit meme I don't know on like 10
years ago
um still a lot of people keeping it
going to this day
keeping the dream alive there's a lot of
really [__] nasty tweets like this
one 26 000 likes if you don't know who
this guy is he's Chris Tyson from Mr
Beast YouTube channel one of the most
important one of the most popular in the
world for kids uh oh kids
he had a beautiful wife and a beautiful
baby and decided he'd rather turn
himself into a gross Hot Topic trans
chick like dude you don't know anything
it's so mean like you are dude you're
the ugliest dude I've ever seen
like I'm sorry I'm not one to bully but
you should transition into someone that
doesn't look so [__] ugly
it's just so amazing care they started
criticizing him now as a dad like
that's just like well so sad and there's
been like these things of like oh Chris
is like a child abuser he's ruining his
family and what Chris said is HRT saved
my life I wouldn't be able to be a
parent to him at all without this
treatment right right and then meanwhile
that's a good parent needs to be a
healthy happy parent without that you're
not yeah you're not going to be there
for your kid exactly meanwhile this
goofy face dude you are [__] hideous
bro
like no wonder you're so bitter you're
probably in the Abba and preach [__]
comment section right now dude
yeah I would prefer if my girl didn't
dress provocatively like that don't
worry you're never that's never gonna
happen
he does need some gender affirming care
that beard is looking very thin
Kali man Low T levels so
God is real and dudes Rock wait are you
it says God is real and dudes Rock
is he saying he's gay because I don't
know what else that means you know
that's like that's a meme that people
who was going around for a while you
never seen that dudes rock yeah is that
that means you're gay well you're free
to take it that way dude that's what he
means I like men I like I but I don't
but dudes Rock I don't like that he has
that in there because I actually agree
dudes do rock yeah dudes Rock there's
Rock dude I like dudes
but but if the problem is he's not a
dude
that is not a dude right there he's a
demon yeah
the people who are coming out and this
the transphobia that you've seen today
is just the I hate it it's so corrosive
it's so toxic it's so disgusting you're
picking on the most marginalized the
most vulnerable people for no [__]
reason
so I think it's important for everybody
to defend them where you can't because
this guy
people like this guy want them to
apparently die if I wrote If I went to
my description on Twitter and wrote I
love dudes are my favorite I [__]
love men like
that's I just think you're a little odd
I don't think I would immediately okay
what if I wrote this
men are I don't want to be spend time
with anything but dudes only dudes in my
life I want to be with dudes I want to
hang out with dudes I want to only be
with dudes always
dudes rock forever okay I would start to
think that was a little sauce yeah thank
you just trying to make that point yeah
indeed
yeah a lot of them are put foreign that
he's just doing this I guess to be a Hot
Topic which to me is again is so
confusing because he has literally
nothing to gain no no no a Hot Topic the
store
oh is that what he's saying yeah wait
what Hot Topic trans chick
okay all right like Hot Topic like the
store with like goth and punk clothes
and stuff okay so uh I slowed down on
watching Mr BEAST's uh video because oh
so this guy's saying I can't watch Mr
Beast anymore yeah because Chris started
wearing nail polish this is so upsetting
dude you can't [__] watch dudes with
nail polish like hello
bunch of [__] that to me
the level of homophobia there is sauce
because if if this guy sees another man
with nail polish and it makes him
uncomfortable
that's like over compensating way too
far
also this guy's a Christian conservative
rapper by the way
he has in his uh description religious
zealot I don't think that's a good thing
what about bigot of the Year bigot of
the year
more pertinent
uh
uh hold on one sec
Ethan have them do a Cushing's test my
dog went through similar Cushings
we had Addison's done repeated issues
like you're talking about what's
Cushing's
I don't know but I saw that donation and
figured that money okay thank you yeah
I'm looking for anything I'll write to
the vet about
smoking or getting that Cushing's
checked
I've heard of that there's all the all
these always crazy obscure diseases
cushions
one sec taking notes it's like I'm
starting to think that it might be
something else and that gives me hope
but at the same time
what are the chances that it's actually
something else so far I'm just going by
his
what I'm saying in front of me
he looks great he's behaving great you
know he's got the energy everything so
I'm just going by that I don't know I
see what's in front of me and he looks
great his creatine levels are currently
at 3.4 which is really really really bad
you guys in the chat probably know
that's really high
[Music]
um
dog has cushions
oh for real
what's Cushing's
found somebody else in the chat set also
their dog had it and it's the same
symptoms as Shredder really but nobody
even mentioned it no it's the first time
I'm hearing that
uh disease is a result when the body
produces too much of a hormone called
cortisol cortisol is produced and stored
in the adrenals two small glands to sit
on top of the kidneys dogs cats and
humans can get Cushing's Disease really
it is more commonly found in dogs than
cats yo so what is the so what is the is
it treatable
symptoms treating Cushing disease most
veterinarians treat both adrenal and
pituitary dependent Cushing's Disease
with medication the only way to quote
cure Cushing disease is to remove the
adrenal tumor if the disease is adrenal
depend okay this is starting to go way
over my head here but here it says it
sounds like it is addressable the common
signs include increased thirsts in
urination increased appetite
yo he has he has been eating more
appetite
huh
panting no pot belly appearance no
muscle weakness and atrophy it's kind of
hard tell with him with all the floof
he's got
darkening and thickening of skin
haven't noticed any of that the
increased appetite is making my ears
perk up a little bit yeah
[__] dude I don't know
well I'll do the test I'll do the test I
mean [__] you give me any test I'll do
it I'll run that [__] yeah uh this one
from
JoJo says as a long time viewer short
time trans woman super amazing issue
defending Chris and the trans Community
as a whole during the scary time for us
dude I'll have you guys back forever
absurd it's obscene it's really sad it's
disgusting it's this is what's happening
it's really sad
I mean in the supposed the freeze
country in the world you know there's
their their solution is just they want
trans people to kill themselves that's
like they just
that's it yeah
yeah crushing will affect the kidneys
definitely check at a very sick dog that
had similar struggles for years happy to
share any info I have well we'll do the
test thank you for that Brittany
you guys have any other obscure dog
diseases you want me to get them tested
for I'll [__] put them through the
ringer
I'm desperate man
God I just want just want him to be okay
so anyway everybody is there's a lot of
pieces of [__] on the internet who are
ganging up
here's a great comment Shredder just
needs to go to the gym
that's true you know you need to be
lifting Shredder when's the last time
you lifted yeah start lifting
no women for a while human growth sermon
dog growth hormone yeah stay away from
the club no girls
[Laughter]
um
so that guy can't watch Mr Beast anymore
because apparently he's friends with a
trans person this whole cancellation
really boils down to
Mr Beast is being canceled because one
of his friends is trans like that this
is the biggest that is wild it's become
the biggest controversy
and Mr BEAST's history by far
the controversy he's friends with a
trans person
who gives a [__] if Mr B's friend is
trans the problem here is that he was is
teaching this [__] to his son [__] this
I hate that
I hate that they go after him as a
parent that's just so
upsetting to me
yeah I mean dude my Theodore's where it
wears theater takes my makeup stuff
it's funny it's funny he's just curious
about everything literally doesn't mean
anything
also it's done your business but you
don't know anything about him as a dad
like why are you pretty you know why go
there because they're they are so
upsetting they are demons they will do
go the worst route
the most despicable takes
I don't know why they have so much hate
in their hearts
but that is their goal so Mr Beast
actually came out and I'm so proud of
him for this
you know because Mr Beast is very
controversy adverse
now being friends with the transversion
should by no means be a controversy
okay is that Olivia drinking a prime we
need to cut to her you're hot red and
busted I will always say these are
delicious really oh my goodness the ice
pop flavor it just tastes like a Frozen
I mean a melted popsicle really dude you
are so busted
fine I'll pack up my stuff get out she's
out this is actually the biggest
endorsement for Prime you'll ever get
there's Olivia in the face of of uh
impossible adverse adverse adversity
laughs
I'm kidding a joy Prime please yeah well
thank you peace and love so I'm kind of
at a loss for words right now
yeah a little bit so we'll get to the
video that kind of started this dialogue
in a big way but Mr Beast is um really
controversy uh adverse he wants to be
the most popular person in the world and
you think of someone like the Rock and
he's just like
I don't have an opinion about anything
I'm just a big dude who who goes in
jungles and fights sometimes humans
sometimes monsters
yeah Mr Beast has more personality than
that so accurate uh but uh
Mr Beast commented under this and then
you could do a rock impression so good
yes
then there's something under your chair
Alfredo is eating excuse me hey you punk
ass enough shredders coming in Shredder
not you better not you not you not you
Shredder good boy Shredder Shredder such
a good boy yesterday he they are like
Hawks under the dinner table because we
stopped giving shredders on a super
strict diet yeah and so he's missing all
the good food he used to get yeah and
last night we dropped this big piece of
bread he was so excited to go for it and
we're like no Shredder drop it drop it
drop it and he did he was so sweet he
dropped it and he walked away from it
and I was like oh my God you're so sweet
you have such good willpower yeah I know
it's very touching
so about the video this guy said this
new Sunny V video really feels invasive
for all the wrong reasons like why did
you make this you delved into the man's
marriage and [__] it's just really
off-putting an unnecessary Mr Beast
responded
he said yeah this is getting absurd
Chris isn't my nightmare he's my [__]
friend and things are fine all this
transphobia is starting to piss me off
so
even though that's probably should be or
it should be self-apparent to everybody
the fact that he actually went and
publicly said this to me I'm glad he's a
good friend and he's a good guy and he
takes the dog forever for that yeah
genuinely yeah genuinely I'm like that's
a big enough you're the man dude yeah I
I write it's important that he did that
it really is and this dude Chris is he's
like his best friend going back like
all the way before YouTube
you know
so love Mr Beast for that
um
here is so in honor of Mr Beast people
really want to go against him
which I think is crazy
uh because he is like pit he's like
pitbull with the real one Mr
International that's true I tied up an
FB you play the sound bite of oh boy
here we go
big news
oh yes sir
[Music]
so what this is is when you scroll these
people's feeds their videos all start
that way
so we thought Mr Beast kind of has that
with his video so we made this to honor
him
I
created Willy Wonka's Chocolate we are
currently surrounded by countless sharks
this is the largest stadium in the world
all of his videos are dubbed in like
every major English
language when you rip it it just is like
a picture it just picks one it picks a
random language yeah when I use 4K video
downloader how weird is that wow I've
never seen that because yeah cam called
me over because we were planning this
and he's just like why are all like
these videos some of them are in one in
Spanish some of them are in Italian like
what's going on
yeah so uh
that so we honor him now let's watch now
this huge dialogue Happening Now started
because of this YouTuber sunnyv2 who
makes video essays the Chris Tyson
dropped an essay about Chris uh titled
why Chris will soon be a nightmare for
Mr Beast
and of course spoiler it's because he's
trans this guy also has made two uh hit
videos on me we love him don't we don't
we folks so he he hasn't missed before
I think they're called here let's see
what are they called we love sunny
the the downfall of Ethan Glenn yeah or
something like that they're in the uh
dog oh they are yeah
I'll just type this
let's see the disheartening downfall of
H3 I'm like bro
come on
h3's new content is awful okay
but then when you go to keemstar he made
one about keemstar you'll look at this
The Unbelievable story of keemstar dream
alert
a magical story of how keemstar Rose to
fame a new Netflix documentary about
just the Glorious story of this guy Kim
star so he did he doesn't have a great
track record in fact people got mad at
him before he made this really weird one
about Ninja that we can watch if we have
time about how because ninja was like I
guess
supporting black lives matter or
something and he made something oh dare
he he's like yo ninja is like
Ninja's biggest controversy you know so
anyway let's watch this it's horrific I
mean it's so gross and I'm so glad that
a lot of people if you look at the like
this like there's 170
eight thousand up 125 000 down so
there is a considerable amount of
pushback which is nice to see yeah and
that's good but it also has a lot of
support which is very disturbing
situation could become a complete
disaster for Mr base brand however it
matters and this guy has this way of
talking that really confused me thank
you thank you he goes uh brand uh this
is how he says gay
so let's begin by going over the drama
before explaining exactly how this will
impact by the way I'm gonna give a
trigger slash rage uh uh rage warning
rage warning because this [__] is dumb
as hell this is even dumber than ever
and preach video
[Laughter]
that's actually what happened they're
like yo I don't like when my girlfriend
one time I walked into my girlfriend and
she was sitting at my best friend's lap
oh a thousand percent those guys yeah
yeah and now you said trauma dumping
during that video okay the cracks were
showing they're deeply insecure and I
think it's important that we make that
very clear yeah
you know
they should hang out with Sebastian
maybe also I got a little bit of
self-report Vibes there when he was
talking about the like extra long hugs
with specific girls oh yeah
long hugs oh yeah I was like what are
you talking about what are you up to
it's like listen how [__] up you are
you're you're timing the the duration of
your girl like yeah you're insecure
brother I have never once timed the uh
duration of my significant others hugs
with other people oh wow that's [__]
nuts yes that is a self-report you are
insecure oh my God
this channel in mid-2022 fans began to
notice that Chris Tyson was changing in
the early days he represented the
quintessential Southern gun and truck
loving dude I just think that's so funny
yeah he was up he was a good old boy he
wore a hat
and he was from meat lovers yeah he
loves meat he's a quintessential man
dude yeah
Chris began to display increasingly
feminine traits this dude painted his
[__] nails and that's one of their
plots oh my God not like every guy
including our Zaki boy has done that in
like especially the last year or two
it's been a huge Trend I think I have
the same colors on it of course if I'm
being completely honest yeah oh [__]
[Applause]
no but honestly like it's fun who gives
a [__] yeah
you know everyone's people have painted
their nails for years and years you're
just decorating yourself man you used to
be a cool masculine dude and after I saw
your nails I think you're gay yeah
you used to be a cool dude you used to
[__] on people's Lawns that was Alpha
you used to you're used to [__] in
people's cars
well he didn't [__] on the car well leak
rosebuds yeah League all over or
something which you will see in the uh
H3 Lord that is I was so happy to relive
that's that that's such a good story
by the way can I coach I haven't watched
it yet can I just call attention to
Zach's shirt here oh yeah yeah so this
this went to the top of the subreddit
that someone saw it at Kohl's
and it's Joker surfing on a Hawaiian
shirt oh [__] so I just want to give a
shout out to whoever I'm sorry I don't
know the user's name but I found it on
the Kohl's website and I'm like yo it's
actually the Joker Joker and Batman both
surfing
that's like if anybody designed a shirt
just for Zach yeah totally 100 percent
wow yes so uh anyway
there's I love the dramatic and the
scary music
on February 3rd what is this
the first sign of trouble
it's making tweets such as I finally got
my nails done at a nail tech
additionally Chris would highlight that
his facial appearance had changed
significantly since the start of the
pandemic which accompanied another post
reading okay so in four different
Customs I had to prove I was myself
because I quote look nothing like my
passport pick so much that I'm
considering updating my passport do you
see any resemblance prompting replies
such as that you went from man to by the
way we looked into this guy's Channel he
is like the most pathetic basement
dwelling Quarter Pounder wannabe of all
this is very plywood eight likes right
are like no no no oh nine thousand okay
replies yes wow Elon mixed it up uh it's
changed a little bit yeah
Chris responded by stating now to be
honest I just really started taking my
mental health seriously and eating
better yet his Twitter photos kept
insinuating that Chris was becoming more
feminine
he's he's turning gay guys dude he put
down the tap water there's estrogen in
that
oh
okay with the same kind of guy kind of
look showing up in his Mr Beast
appearances for example on the 6th of
January 2023 Beast reacts uploaded a
video titled istrapped a GoPro to a fish
in which Chris dressed in a way that
prompted comments such as Chris has been
adopting more and more traits that
remind me of my grandmother okay
some people just gonna ignore Chris's
Nails Chris had to have lost a bet the
look is getting Wilder the response
countless viral by the way this guy is
just reading all the hate comments about
Chris great thank you I'm sure Chris is
gonna love this video so this is what's
interesting he's taking like
him
like people being happy for him that
he's like
fixing his mental health and then like a
bunch of like 12 year old Fortune
groupers that's alert that's what word
Dan taught me
what is groiper like can I say that or
no
can you say it I mean is it is it a word
that people know
uh yeah some people right Bears people
that are as online as I am I guess which
I liked it it's got a number simply
isn't it what does it mean
uh it's like the the Nick Fuentes crowd
alt-right Ropers huh
kids loved Hitler
it loves kids love Hitler wait is it
like grifters no no it's like white
National assault right people okay yeah
so he's taking courage from like
these probably
I do yeah I'll take a coffee actually
wait I think I
I think I made coffee and then left it
on the thing I feel like this new
episode is like the most h a d h three
it is it is well there's a lot going on
and there's not many of us so we're
doing our best yeah I'm trying to stay
on the rails but it's hard yep
Abba and Shakir and Abba
yes I I need it to be hot that's for
then for mine thank you
so anyway okay this outfit by the way
he's like and again look at this sweater
isn't it a little feminine I love that
sweater I think it's actually really
good yeah yeah it's like and I like the
necklace too hot though it's like not
I mean black and white stripes it's
pretty neutral
it's like fashionable yeah
no it's nice it's nice so I love that
premise that we're all just supposed to
accept here he's looking a little gay we
can all agree I think Jimmy looks a
little more off than Krista playing with
one of those clappers
okay all right
in a way that prompted comments such as
Chris has been adopting more and more
traits that remind me of my grandmother
okay
Chris had to have lost a bet the look a
hundred percent a hundred likes yo are
we gonna talk about the fact that this
gay dude's painting his nails like
that's not an equal two sides
is getting Wilder the response to the
video then pumped countless viral tick
tocks such as this one with 700 000
likes stating how did Chris go from this
to this While others even made the claim
that Carl had turned him gay so yeah
there it is only Carl and Chris are
painting their nails and 20 what is this
from last year
literally everybody is doing it
everybody
yeah it's definitely where do you guys
live like what I think I have Chris's
nail polish too that's uh OPI I forget
the name of the car it's like a Tiffany
blue can I ask a question
so yesterday when I was in the basement
Theodore started painting my nails oh
yeah Theodore has an L uh kit and
they're really gay colors too it was
like pink and purple he loves doing a
rainbow no should I be worried yeah it
should be sober loves everything rainbow
I think I need to be worried
by the way so this is a serious point in
this video that people say Carl made
turned Chris gay uh Carl is not even gay
he is apparently
uh asexual and you know what they call
themselves Ace which I thought was
awesome Ethan was so delighted when I
explained that to him I didn't know
about that he's like that's the coolest
nickname ever oh they're Ace that's
[__] I mean you're not wrong like it
it is a cool it's like it's so that they
have something short like like I'm bi or
something like that and so it's it's
shortening asexuals I was like dude
these guys are all like Top Gun as [__]
and then it's like yo uh you know
everyone goes out trying to get laid
it's like yo did you get any no I'm Ace
I'm Ace I'm Ace all the time baby I love
boiling I'm good live
yeah I got it very good and and
what happened what did we miss
he played that he played the ace Family
song
he's working like Austin's getting mad
yeah it's very artistic yeah yeah just
went with it oh here we go a grouper is
a crypto fascist are we combining those
not crypto like cryptocurrency like
hidden okay okay
crypto fascists usually originating from
4chan who call into talk shows with
initially innocent sounding questions
and then try to get the host to respond
to increasingly aggressive Neo-Nazi
talking points this is um seems like
overly specific it's definitely broader
than that but okay I mean this sounds
like something they would do but
it's not only people that they're both
they're like online Nazi yeah that's
just weirdos yeah yeah yeah like pepper
the frog type people I love that I love
that name
groiper
sounds like groper
yeah they like they like that he's even
talking about like one person making the
other person gay he doesn't he says that
with a straight face yeah and as you
guys know gay is contagious
we're going and that's basically what
he's saying okay this guy's Sunny too by
the way is a huge Channel his videos get
tons of views his videos of me got a lot
of views as always
great juicing hey yeah now this was
pretty ridiculous as Carl isn't even
that feminine and Chris had come out as
bike he's not even that feminine very
feminine
oh my God like like where's the bar
who's gauging his femininess exactly
he's not even that he's only a little
gay not gay enough of course to convert
not gay enough to be contagious yes yeah
yes it seems like satire dude it really
does this video is insane like insane
tick tocks such as this one with 700 000
likes stating how did Chris go from this
to this While others even made the claim
that Carl had turned him gay no this was
pretty ridiculous as Carl isn't even
that feminine and Chris had come out as
bisexual years before he and Carl had
even met the true Catalyst for Chris
Tyson's feminization instead seemed to
have come from his marriage in January
2022 Chris would post a photo with his
wife to his
thinking behind the corner
guns out yo is there a trans person here
hands up CCTV uh footage yeah
this the family photo stopped altogether
fans also noticed that God liked his
wedding ring dude I can't with this
[__] [__] oh my god dude
stop with the vocal fry is there
actually something wrong with him
because who talks like that no together
it's vocal fries I I don't know if it's
an accent or what it is but well I I he
sounds Australian to me am I right on
that yeah Hassan was doing that thing
yesterday gay uh he's like talking like
George Takei or wherever his name is
[Music]
musculature something like a fabulous
man in theater
he is very theatrical yeah you know I
had that thought too that he sounds like
the impresario of like some some opera
or something yeah you should announce it
the thing is he's recording this
voiceover all right do something a bit
Kinder with your time maybe you know
what it sounds kind of uh gay
be real here the thing is you have to
imagine he's in the studio doing voice
over and he's lit he's doing his lines
and he goes and that was a bit gay
you know what you're doing
he'd removed his wedding ring with the
Ring's absence correlating perfectly
with the very first post in which he'd
painted his nails
circles in the circles about the nail
polish
the very same day he took off his ring
thing the ring he painted his nail
all together fans
that's what I'm saying sorry he knows
what he's doing he goes in the studio
and literally records this he's
Instagram yet after this the family
photo stopped altogether
okay
some of us will get this reference but
people are pointing out he sounds like
General Reichert from Elden ring the
snake dude he talks exactly like that do
you remember no no you played it on mute
never mind then
you know I just don't trust me he does
together
well was he a snake guy yeah the big the
giant snake boss
right there that guy I remember his
voice yeah yeah
Angela
Angela Angela
thank you to uh Shannon together we can
misgender the very good
he'd removed his wedding ring with the
Rings absence correlating perfectly with
the very first post in which he'd
painted Illuminati proven right there
Illuminati Illuminati no yeah this is
like not the red circles you probably
didn't need to include this as uh
evidence
as you can tell his the colors are quite
gay and that is the day his family went
missing the death like watching a date
line right
as you can tell his the ring came off
the very day that his face looked a
little more gay that day
spotted on a boat that night yeah I was
getting rid of it
notice that he'd removed his wedding oh
you'll notice he was wearing torn jeans
which is a little gay a little sign of a
conflict with the white far
this man look at this the ripped jeans
oh my ring with the Rings absence
correlating perfectly with the very
first post in which he'd painted his
nails Chris confirmed the split in a
post from March 2023 reading for a
little over a year now me and Katie have
been separated with this also confirming
that Chris's transformation began as
soon as his marriage came to an end
Chris went from lighting campfires and
raising a family with his beautiful wife
to now trying to be a wife with his man
buns and long nails like bro you don't
need to show this no you don't these are
people just being like extremely
transphobic and disgusting like you like
like this is not a valid argument he's
putting this forward like there's two
sides but he's only showing one side
well yeah really it's just pretty
one-sided it's a really
but so far to me he's reading it as if
these are comments he's agreeing with
yeah the person making the video
otherwise why would you put those in
there or that they're serious points
yeah these are serious points they're
not
he went he's gay have you all considered
this man was lighting campfires what
what is this rugged fantasy you have for
Chris's life
he was colliding campfires around a
Christmas tree
I feel like that should go against their
point for someone like being so I love
trucks or whatever to then like even
people like that will go through things
like this I think it's normalizing a 100
love yeah that's a very interesting
you've got it backwards I think I think
what happened was he was like I want to
be edgy and I want more attention and
also I think Mr Beast needs a
lgbtq character he says that he says
that no that's a great that is a really
good point love it really does show
that these these con these people who
are in the closet
struggling deeply with their mental
health are amongst all of us could be
anywhere of course yeah
so there it is I'm happy for Chris proud
of him yeah
I mean it sounds like a well I'm sure
this has been really hard on his mental
health I can only imagine how bad it is
but sounds like what he was doing the
transition is really helping his mental
health so
I agree I'm happy for him for that they
said it saved his life so yeah he said
HRT saved saved their life
um
but again if you think about this
logically Chris had nothing to gain and
everything to lose by doing this yeah
like the only plausible reason for him
to do this is because he had to yeah why
would anybody want to go through all
this like
yeah it's not a surprise to him you know
or anyone as the criticism continued to
pile Chris announced that he'd be taking
a break from social media and while
there was a possibility that Chris would
make efforts to return to his former
self he'd rather do the opposite and
double down on his feminine he's not
double double down
is is finding himself and his true
identity he had an opportunity to go
back to being a man but he doubled down
he doubled down on his mistake that's
what he makes it
oh brother
what a [__]
little douche
but do the opposite and double down on
his feminine image showing up to the
Kids Choice Awards looking like this
before like the announcement that he'd
been doing HRT the way he says that is
so gross yeah showing up like this
doubled down on his freakish Behavior
two months which according to a quick
Google search is the medical process for
changing genders because you've got to
Google that dummy wait wait
I mean that's fine if he had to Google
it but what but he acts like nobody
knows what HRT is
and just the way he worded that he could
just for those of you don't know is this
would be a way to say that but according
to Google are they like maybe it's
important for him to make a clear to his
audience like I don't know [__] about
this Hey listen I I I hate this so much
I don't even know nothing I don't even
know anything about nobody would be gay
to even know what that is right
I had to look this up making the
announcement that he'd been doing HRT
for approximately two months which
according to a quick Google search is
the medical process
hey you could do that with anything
right I was like
according to Google uh vocal fries when
you
draw out the ending syllable just for
changing genders Chris would expand on
this by stating inform consent HRT saved
my and many others lives the hurdles GNC
people have to jump through to get
life-saving gender affirming Healthcare
in a first world country is wild to me
just let people make informed decisions
about their own bodies but that's pretty
much such that's like Case Closed yep
end of the video's over yeah or is it
which received a positive response from
both Carl and Mr Beast who wrote got you
I did one more heart than Carl because
I'm a better friend while his co-workers
and others weren't so welcoming there
goes a father figure the king and now
here comes this like psychotic riper
Freakazoid who this got 80 000 likes
though that is so painful it hurts it
hurts my heart
really does
that's really sad I think that's why
it's so important that we are so vocal
about supporting
trans people is because
I mean what the [__] how is it not so
obvious that these people are wrong and
like in 30 years they're gonna be
they're going to be on video
saying this stuff they're like they're
you know I mean the internet's forever
that's interesting because I've thought
so often about how much this reminds
like the when we were in high school in
this country the debate was the big
debate was about gay marriage that was
like a huge thing right and back and
forth and then they even passed a law to
to ban it specifically and then other
stuff happened and back and forth and
it was very similar to this it was a
very divisive issue that in and just
like this issue the majority of people
were
on the side of supporting gay marriage
but there was a sizable minority that
were super against it and the type of
[__] that people said and all the kind
of bigoted stuff they should just be so
thankful it was the pre Facebook friends
like if Twitter existed during that
whole debate there'd be so many receipts
people would be pulling on each other
all the time to embarrass uh people and
this is a it's the exact same situation
the same thing but it's here now forever
and documented you know
yeah how can you not see that like you
were those people because these people
go oh well you know gay marriage like
everyone's kind of accepted it now this
is kind of silly I mean not everybody
but most people it's not everybody but
for a lot of us it's a very obvious yeah
part of everyday life now so the same
people who would say actually there's a
lot right they condemn some stuff like
uh moderate and but they're like no but
trans just goes too far how can you not
see that that it's the same thing
like you're just the old you're the out
of touch old person that doesn't
understand the younger people that's all
you are so obvious right
and this tweet it's like for us like
we're parents we know like your kid is
the most important thing to you in the
world and for them to say that about
about Chris as a dad it's just so
ugh it's so mean and it's like you don't
know anything about Chris as as the
father father figure that's the [__]
up part you don't know anything about
his father Chris could be the best you
know and this feels so gross like what's
actually the best is Chris that is
healthiest and happiest yeah and it's
just it's really sad that'll make it a
good dad yeah to be happy and healthy
you need you need those fat you need to
be healthy and here in order to be a dad
right what do they prefer yeah without a
dad yeah yes they do yeah yeah they 100
do yeah
and not even kidding
it won't ever be able to look up to Hard
Times create strong men strong men
create good times good times create weak
men and weak men create Hard Times weak
mankind dude I'm sorry this quote which
I I just like a Joe Rogan thing it's so
[__] stupid what even is that from I
don't know what they mean by strong men
do they mean like dudes with muscles who
like believe in Jesus is that strong man
yeah
it's just esoteric yeah I mean but they
just I know themselves into whatever
because Joe Rogan's like I go to the gym
and I take but so that's how is that
helping Society you having muscles
you know
thank you
thanks Chris responded to this comment
by stating this is just more dog
whistling that somehow trans and GNC
folks aren't safe around kids Tucker
begs for me to come back when I leave
for like two days to film he is so loved
and happy kids aren't born with hate
it's taught by people like you and my
child will only know love no I know I'm
going to be a great parent and so is
every other person who puts the love of
their child before everything I made
this decision because I wanted a shop as
my best and happiest self for him in a
way this was for Tucker Chris's response
I'm convinced you're an amazing father
Tucker is lucky to have you you didn't
pass I just want to say those were great
and I that already tells me about him as
a parent you know
weak men make cave times
strong man make math
frog man think good
weak men weak men like Chris who are
trans but this guy's working his ass off
he's like a millionaire he's super
successful so what part of him is weak
like and what part of you is strong
you're [__] on the talking on [__] on
Twitter like what are you doing with
your life I would like to know have the
receipts on how you're a strong man
strong men make Society good
strong man leave hate comments on
Twitter
Tucker
hey
[Laughter]
you and also lucky to have all of those
who surround and support you in his life
as well as I adore that I'm glad you
made that decision by the way I don't
know why the only support comments you
could get have like one like yeah I'm
sure that's not true no I think he's
getting tons of support much easier to
be a parental figure when you're not
sure dysphoria yet he'd also receive an
equal amount of backlash you ripped
apart not with the invert again he goes
I know I know it's scary yeah he hit him
with that invert again he goes equal
amount of backlash it's like yeah you
showed that the whole time he only
showed like two supporting comments with
no legs so far
yet he'd also receive an equal amount of
backlash
and took a father figure away from your
son just so you could paint your nails
and act zesty but you shouldn't even
show that yes that's just like why are
you even reading such a nasty comment
that's not a valuable addition it's not
a compelling argument even a little it's
just me right I mean it's like yeah he
did it just so he compare his nails you
know like why even read that and ask
zesty
whatever that means
you ever been zesty in your life a beer
get me that oh God a beer has
you just want to see his profile
kind of Justified right we don't need to
like I don't know man you if you want to
bring the heat
we don't need to for the Twitter adverse
you know well you've already said it
that's not war here Dan's pulling it up
so you know we can do it no that's I
think absolutely not Oh I thought you're
pulling it up I was like whoa Dan's
coming with me no no no no no okay no no
no no no no we'll move on we don't want
to talk about a beer and Son no no no no
no no no well
a beer hahaha
this man thinks being gay is zesty
[Music]
beer I like I like zesty food huh
given a book huh a beer a beer huh I'll
bet you if a beer let himself be a
little more zesty maybe he'd have a bit
more fun yeah
have a beer a beer give us some
vegetables
dude who doesn't like zest that's crazy
I put zest in everything I want to live
I hate everyone's life needs a little
zest you know what I mean I feel like
they say that they're dry you're dry
you're boring dude yep
all right pathetic he will get torn up
you pulled it up
no he's not doing that no I'm not doing
it
at school I want to have friends around
his house a life full of difference and
being alone must have missed the point
in that tweet how's this for him when
you're depriving him of a father figure
it's like this is a 10 year old I mean
he's he's not dead although it would be
he's he he's still alive
you know
Father Figure he he needs to be a real
father figure and beat be like my dad
who beat me with a [__] belt
yeah staying and came home drunk and
beat me like a good father figure beat
the zest out that's right ain't no zest
in this house boy I don't want to see
you walk around all zesty like again you
understand me be a real father figure
like me now
ain't no zest loud in this house boy the
only the only zest I'm allowing is in
that real nice cocktail your mother
makes me love it little there's some
limes there you know what I'm saying a
little twist I love me some zest and a
Twist of my beverage not my boy and if
she leaves it out there's pale to pay
let me tell you it's weird because that
sounds good so that's this good it's
like usually used in a net positive way
yeah no it's like zest is like appealing
it's good it's like he's paid he's being
patronizing yeah obviously he's trying
to be mean
no I know he is but I feel like they're
using the word wrong it's still a great
quality well they're using it as uh it's
fruity yeah oh he's being he's being
fruity he's being nasty but I don't know
hey be a real father figure and put
bottle up all of your emotions unable to
ever make meaningful connections with
anybody yeah
I want you you need to be a real father
figure and die without anybody ever
knowing who you really are
a good old father figure you know
be a good father figure so when you get
home your kids run turn off the TV and
run to their rooms because they're
scared of you
that's the father figure they're talking
about it although Chris wasn't altered
by these comments as he'd once again
reiterate his certainty in a new post
reading it's never too late to start
being yourself which will save praise
from Mr based as well as Nolan and Carl
however these comments also added extra
fuel to the fire in a few years
bro how are you real person
why uh this is like AI generated biggest
but make it like kind of transphobic and
bigoted right you got it uh make sure
and make sure in the voice generation
make my voice real zesty
[Laughter]
[Music]
with uh these comments also added extra
fuel to the fire in a few years
he's doing that on purpose I think he's
doing it he thinks it's his trademark
now
I mean trademark is being annoying yeah
yeah Australia is a big country maybe
maybe it's like a regional accident I
don't think so who walks around like
that I've heard an Australia
they would evolve out of that they would
have they would have learned better
I've watched below Deck Down Under I
love down under yeah that's one of my
favorites yeah
so he shows this tweet again which is
just horrible as if it's a real argument
uh in a few years look back at this
thread and remember they were never your
friends only Yes Men cowards hope you
come out of this safe
yeah what the [__] yeah he's responded
to this with a simple opinion irrelevant
ratio to which the original comments I'm
glad that he's being a vocal yeah he's
the man I'm so glad he's the [__] man
I have 30 followers so go ahead and
ratio me I'll still rest easy knowing
that I'm not a coward who idly sits by
watching my friend ruin his own life I
need to share this
you need to be a good friend the only
reason he will share this stuff is
because he agrees with this statements
of course he thinks this guy owned Mr
Beast yeah otherwise he would not
include this kind of stuff a good friend
would uh bully him into
repressing it a good friend would call
him the F slur and never see him again
ah
wife in some ways it was nice to see the
boys standing up but Chris on Twitter
however the secret operation has already
begun to change the dynamic within the
videos for example in a recent live
stream titled opening a thousand mystery
art boxes Chris would once again dress
in quite a feminine way and while
everybody participated as usual the
energy and Vibe didn't feel nearly as
smooth as it normally does it felt as
though there was an unaddressed elephant
in the room and therefore everybody was
in their head as opposed to being in the
present moment enjoying each other's
company maybe everybody was simply too
so I get he's trying to show that
there's like this insane conflict in the
room and he's literally just showing
random shots like I do not
I just don't see or feel that it's like
grasping at straws and also Jimmy was
literally like everything's fine you
freaks yeah
busy opening packages but Chris did make
these bizarre jokes about Jimmy being
female making him incredibly
uncomfortable you wouldn't have thought
a [__] second about it if he wasn't
transitioning oh my God Jimmy look they
drew you Jimmy they drew you so well
it looks just like him oh yes oh my God
it's Jimmy I didn't fan art this is what
we were looking for the be brave dude
you guys what's the word that's just
grasping it's this is weird I can see
discomfort I don't see anything no yeah
I just saw a friend just like a group
stream you know and it's all cut up it's
like what the [__] are you trying to
show me
ah
um
okay here this is interesting a beer we
might have something good for you we
made a special sauce for you our beers
bottled up zesty Secret Sauce never be
your true self bottle up the zap never
be your food though from a beer
that's awesome
that's great Cameron you just knocked up
uh let me thank some folks here
Alexander said
when did the weakness and insecurity
demonstrated by the fool who made this
suddenly become strength real Alphas are
lgbtq AI plus allies we love our kids
we're too busy to go to the gym all the
time and we are for treating women with
respect and equals uh sounding beta to
me
thank you Alexander I agree with I
couldn't agree with you more I mean this
whole notion of strong men is like okay
what is a strong man somebody that like
eats only meat like what do you have
like a cartoonish idea of what a real
man means it's so ironic too because
they're talking about them like being so
strong but they have like the most
fragile mind
um you know what I mean everything
they're so insecure about everything I
know I'm doing that all night I know
it's like you're so you're actually so
weak yeah
yeah
they have they have Mommy Dad or daddy
issues clearly
which is why it's so funny that he did
this whole thing up you're depriving
them of a real father figure
be honest be kind Mr stupid that is my
tagline becoming even weirder when each
member started even weirder like well
what was weird so far and well look
Jimmy tries to divert conversation any
way possible
if you say so
I did not that seems like a fantasy in
your head dude honest be kind that is my
tagline becoming even weirder when H
members started to pay each other
compliments hey nice shirt thanks dude
nice shirt I do like Carl's Shirt By the
way that shirt's fun I wonder what that
is
thanks dude nice shirt thanks nice shirt
nice
shoes for the most part oh Mr Beast
wouldn't compliment his shirt
what that means what is even because
Chris is wearing like a a woman's top
but what is the point that uh that that
Sunny uh here is trying no clue here it
is he's gonna tie it all together I
thought the live stream was devoid of
awkward moments however there's nothing
his I think the point he's making is
that Mr Beast wouldn't compliment
Chris's shirt
he said nice shoes which proves that
there's a lot of trouble behind the
scenes this is like more
demented than cubanon
[Laughter]
I'm gonna pause that a weird time before
you should roll back and play that last
sentence he says oh okay oh yes oh my
God
that is my tagline becoming even weirder
when H members started to pay each other
compliments hey nice shirt thanks dude
nice shirt hey nice shirt thanks dude
nice shirt thanks nice shirt nice
shoes for the most part the live stream
was devoid of awkward moments however it
would see he even says like there's
nothing really weird of awkward moments
so what the what what did you so he cut
the like one miss wow
quite of awkward moments however it
would act as fodder for another 100
million views worth it did Ian leave
yeah yeah you've done his way to
Coachella
on a mission he's gonna did Sam go with
him
uh I don't know maybe I don't know I
don't see Sam she's not here so probably
if you guys are going to Coachella you
see Ian give him some water or something
he's out there suffering
or don't get if you see Gabe don't give
him one don't give any liquids
don't eat don't drink even if you see
him passed out
do not understand
whatever it takes not to pee
I kind of agree with him to be honest I
[__] hate having to be of festivals
ruins the whole damn thing
but anyway
shoes for the most part the live stream
was devoid of all the moments however it
would act as fodder for another 100
million views worth of Drama and critics
that is actually really [__] nasty
look at the views on these whoa I'm
gonna miss the goat 30 million Chris
sitting closer to Jimmy what like he
wants to [__] Jimmy because he's trans
now that's so demented
20 million
Mr Beast confronts Chris after coming
out that did not happen 15 million views
Jimmy felt so uncomfortable in this
video 13 million
nice wow
you know it [__] me
I don't think in my lifetime I've ever
experienced
where it was so
overtly
accepted by so many people
to just straight up
demonize a group of people like I I
don't know I think it's because there
was no internet like yeah social media
like Dan was saying I guess the I mean
and now everybody gets to put their
opinion
in a very visible way I don't know it's
just like people are so comfortable
being so openly transphobic yeah when uh
when we were in high school
people scream the epsler I think it was
even more
the F slur oh yeah like it was it was
that bad it was even worse maybe I mean
it see it feels more focused because
kids are more tolerant and accepting of
it somehow it's the old people who are
super transphobic oh I I absolutely
agree with that I mean this I think this
is young people on Tick Tock right yeah
you're right old people yeah no but I
think yeah there's certainly plenty of
young people that are certainly
transphobic and and even homophobic uh
but I think you know the younger
generation on the whole
is much more accepting of these things
than my generation because it definitely
was like I said I mean it was the big
debate was about gay marriage not only
yeah 20 years ago and uh I don't know
that there was ever a point where it was
like gay people shouldn't exist or I
mean I know there was but like in my
lifetime were they like no no the
popular opinion was like no gay people
like Joe Rogan's on the radio being like
trans people are lying and they
shouldn't exist I mean Rush Limbaugh it
definitely it definitely was there I
mean it took a different form I was
maybe I was I think there was no social
media that's the difference exactly my
parents were pretty like Progressive
with all that stuff so maybe yeah mine
too and so where I grew up if you were
gay it would be like
you couldn't be on
be up you couldn't
uh Ruth said Ethan you live in
California try living in the Deep South
okay yeah all right it's not a hate
Olympics you know
you know this could be Russian
propaganda for all I know Americans are
such idiots though [__] Take debate
and cause of Civil War because Chris
were wearing blouse it's like too easy
for them
autism Chris likely believes that people
will slowly adapt to his new appearance
over time but is this really going to
happen well maybe it's difficult to say
as the situation is fairly unique
especially when considering Chris's
reputation and influence however if
Chris continues to transition would it
be unreasonable to say that he could
jeopardize some of the personality
traits which made him a successful
member in the first place yeah I don't
think he cares I think he wants to be
himself dude I don't think he's thinking
like uh what if people are gonna like me
as much yeah
think it's way deeper than that
my favorite line is coming up perhaps
the opposite will happen and he'll
instead pick up new personality traits
that better resonate with the current Mr
Beast audience this was put forward in
many comments supportive of Chris who
implied that there'll be millions of
queer kids who look up to him although
this doesn't necessarily mean that it'll
add any value to the videos it's got
nothing to do with the video a
transactional wave yeah about it it's
still weird so you're such a creep dude
this man is trying to be himself but it
really here's I'm telling you it gets
better Mr Bass has likely cultivated a
massive LGBT audience all of whom are
already watching anyway and if we've
learned anything from Hollywood in
recent years it's that adding over the
top LGBT characters for the sake of
relatability rarely works as intended
and is often nothing more than a
distraction from the premise of the
movie or video so this man literally
thinks Chris is transitioning to add an
over-the-top lgbtq character to of Mr
Beast Universe wow
yeah yeah they decided in the boardroom
uh you know that they needed to more
diversity on the Mr beastcast so hey
Chris do you mind um do you mind
transitioning for us anything for the
show mosh
do you mind taking hormone replacement
uh if you do Transit hormone transition
treatment craze you get an island
in this video transition into a woman
I injected my best friend yeah with tons
of estrogen I made my best friend drink
tap water for a whole month it didn't
happen
hey Zach or Zach are you cool for the
show sure anything for the Showbox
come on let's see what happens you
already got the nails yeah yeah the hair
you're halfway you're halfway oh and I'm
wearing [__] ripped jeans too there
you go
Sunny V2 video yeah that's that's gonna
be cool how's that the sound guy Zach
the sound
he became a nightmare before 83. this
guy [__]
uh rather oh wow on top of this it can
be uncomfortable and unrelatable for the
silent majority although yeah again I
don't think it matters if he's
unrelatable the dude said he was gonna
[__] kill himself if he didn't do
this also do you remember reading that
yeah guess
all the people who don't have someone to
look up to who is non-binary all those
kids who are confused with how they feel
like yeah that are surrounded by people
like you yeah I don't think literally no
offense to all the uh CIS white males
out there but I don't think they need
more representation right I totally
we're good yeah they're covered I've got
lots of Heroes
there's plenty to choose from there's no
I don't think there's any like straight
white kids who are like I don't know how
to piece this white straight
how do I navigate this world
you guys will be fine
bro as we have seen a situation like
Chris's does have the potential to
create an otherworldly amount of
discussion which could be seen as a
benefit for the Mr Beast brand drama is
good for growth 100 that would be an
easy way this is [__] gross because
Mr Beast has never leveraged drama
he has always 100 dependent on his
content only and again this implication
that this is somehow a calculated move
by them he's like that that he's making
Chris transition for content is [__]
mental I mean I'm pretty sure that this
clip is taken out of the complete
opposite context exactly that's exactly
because if he's probably talking about
anything is about
if I got in drama it would be good but I
stay out of drama 100 so and he's like
never done drama before yep how is he
using this here it's the complete
opposite of what he's saying yep so it's
almost as good faith as uh
we gotta work on that because I don't
think Abba deserves the Dignity of his
having his fullness okay I gotta
I gotta know which one is which I really
don't I don't know which ones which one
is ABBA
Yo Gabba Gabba Yo Gabba Gabba
Yo Gabba Gabba's dub it's a kids show
yeah
uh either talk I'm doing something I
can't find anything without them
together
um
Urban leech which one
um maybe on their Instagram do they have
individual do they not have individual
Instagram that's funny wait King
preached the okay okay coconuts and
Barbados is is reach how about wobble
and Screech oh coconuts and Barbados is
is um
so it's the opposite of
what yeah me too I thought it was the
other way around so
hey man good one man I know okay got
another one man
double and mumble
see I like the reach though because
there Texas okay wait wait wait I gotta
keep reach yeah we need a good Abba
I mean
try another but the second Shadow Babble
Babble and reach oh he was he was
bubbling that's not bad that's actually
your first I'm liking that yeah that's
solid I'm liking that waiver and reach
no that one's not uh
she had the building constructed but
just a wife
that's just me
I love them
[Music]
also the insecure thing really hits them
hard too yeah that got under the skin
that would be useful to Leverage
shaky and Flaky here I'll read you the G
the jet GPS ones mom fumble and Grumble
doubt and pout
um
flail and fail I don't know about
statuted and comedy yeah it's a tough
gig it's not for right not for everybody
I think Babylon reached I think we found
it because he was Babylon or blah blah
and reach oh wait actually no wait reach
was the one that was really battling
my brother my brother's in college right
now and so I started I told him watch
you use chat gbt to help you write with
your papers is he doing and he started
doing it oh my God gotta change his life
[__] life I can't imagine that I made
your brother expelled his teacher was
open to it
of course they know like he's like if
you want to use it yeah [__] use it
holy [__] yeah this is the future man
yeah oh my God it's a [__] homework
but wait how are they okay with that I
don't feel like I can't do anything
about it yeah yeah
he's like I'd rather read that than
whatever dumb [__] you were gonna write
yeah it might actually be interesting
here's chat gp's final uh suggestion
stumble do it how do you do it how do
you do it
no I do what you say it different every
time and it's not GPT no he said jet GPS
earlier
[Music]
stumble and reach
mutter and reach confused reminder
oh Mudder hesitant and reach these suck
tremble and reach Gaff and reach dude
this suck
hey by the way since uh Zach just did a
little xqc meme I've seen a couple
people in the chat say that xqc had
a very good take on this whole Sunny
situation oh that's good yeah I also
thought I knew those guys are I mean at
the end of the day that's the thing that
I'm conflicted about xqc because he does
really dumb things but I think at the
end of the day he is a good guy when it
comes to stuff like that I saw Ludwig
made a great video uh uh defending them
and [__] on sunny and I'm not
surprised that xqc did also but I'm
happy he did obviously yeah that's great
also I'm not surprised
I think he's good with that kind of
stuff right love
yeah like social I guess is very he'll
drop like a horrible take every now and
then but yeah
in general mostly decent just don't mean
you know who someone's been dropping
like consistent horrible takes that I
didn't expect was that that World of
Warcraft guy all right smuggle yeah oh
asthma gold he's been kind of going down
a shitty path he used to have pretty
good takes on social stuff but I've
noticed that too he seems to uh
be uh I don't agree no oh you're what
was it there was something just like
this week there was this one I mean I
know you're a Stan so you're gonna
as it was that one thing with uh like
he's told like a mom to move
because she lived in that one city with
the battle oh yeah just like just move
yeah yeah yeah yeah but if you look into
that there was some lacking context
anymore okay
it wasn't that though it was something
just like within the last week but yeah
it must have been what you were talking
about too he has very he's very blunt
sometimes and it comes off super rude
and dumb sometimes I do agree with them
uh let's finish this video we're close
okay we're close the problem is this
type of situation is probably the last
thing that Mr base wants to attract as
he's forced to agree with Chris's
position because he has no way of
manipulating the situation without being
painted as the bad guy it's a lose-lose
situation I think Jimmy is in and with
his [__] uh I I just it is
okay yeah it's over the top inescapable
situation if he kicks out Chris canceled
if he don't his channel will die for
real dude you're no little silly stop it
this will not affect his viewership at
all come on you kidding me you're gonna
stop watching Mr B's because his friend
is trans right no
um and since we were just slandering
asthma gold to be fair to him
this was uh
this was his Take On the Sunny stuff can
you read it yeah it says uh how is it
that people have nothing better to do
than micromanage and mauled about the
lifestyles of content creators is
exhausting how opinionated internet
users are about the personal lives of
people they never met holy [__] I think
Nico responded Nico
when it's snico everybody Farms
you're just fun to make fun of dude why
is it that you guys support trans people
and not me
I deserve support too and then
as men replied when Chris pulls out a
gun threatens you because of this tweet
let me know right yeah yeah
so there you go good take okay he's back
he's back he's back back people
an inescapable situation is a pretty
good way of describing the drama which
is also why it deserves the harsh label
of being a nightmare Jimmy has no option
but to publicly Express acceptance of
Chris's transition a silence or even
worse disapproval would come with
obvious
boob guy seven
zero likes zero like comment from boob
guys seven you can tell he's weirded out
because but can't do anything because of
backlash and because it's Chris boob guy
seven boob guys
because he's
seven years old probably very possible
it's not even a joke I should straight
up
it was probably or he was born in 2007.
which would make him cut him old
I'd make him like 20. no I wouldn't why
am I say that what's the math I I missed
what you were even
making 16 16. let's stop let's move on
quickly violence or even worse would
come with obvious severe repercussions
however in accepting Chris's transition
Jimmy implies that this will be the new
normal within the content thus annoying
a different group of people many of whom
will never express their true feelings
and may rather simply click on fewer Mr
Beast videos if this man has a gay dude
in his uh logo
while saying
people are going to stop watching
because of Chris yeah is that ironic I
don't know maybe Tyler is Tyler uh title
though is I'm a defective human okay
well again gay Gay's fine it's just
trans no like we've moved on okay videos
if this is the case Jimmy has no option
but to accept this fate as removing
Chris from the videos in any kind of way
it could create an even more severe
media Firestorm the only clean solution
should things go south might be for
Chris to resign himself and even then
rumors and bad press will be unavoidable
whether it be arrogance or ignorance
Chris seems oblivious to how this whole
thing might impact Jimmy forgetting that
he achieved his current level of success
by avoiding this exact type of drama so
this [__] what a gusting freak
Chris should have considered
resigning all Mr Beast done for him
instead of
uh transitioning also he puts Chris
he he
paints Chris a real person as like a
parasite like as an unsolvable problem
yeah and it's like he's almost like
encouraging him just to kill himself
like I know he's not saying that but
imagine that this story is saying he
should resign from the channel nobody
said even resigning is still going to
cause uh controversy right people
question
imagine you're Chris watching this he
goes you're a problem you're a parasite
Your Existence is ruining your best
friend's life there's nothing you can do
to fix it
right trans people are already suicidal
by by numbers or they're more likely
right they're more likely to experience
suicidal ideation
so like what's the solution here dude
let's just let's you know what's Chris's
options here sunnyv2 you [__] animal
disgust like I don't think
yeah
it's disgusting I'm glad he's getting
dragged he actually been losing Subs I'm
surprised to see too good that's good
can you pull that up well I I have seen
quite
a few people uh taken off guard by this
video like his fans right
um that they didn't so I don't know if
this is just like
way more openly uh sort of bigoted than
his content typically is or
um
I mean it seems like it's right in the
pocket with the type of content he makes
uh I've watched some of his videos and
stuff it's usually
well like so I was saying he has one
about the ninja which I haven't watched
yet I wanted to watch it with you guys
where he
um
let's see here I probably don't have
time with how slowly we go it's already
4 30. here let me just see Ninja was the
Undisputed king of fortnite Battle
Royale there's no doubt about it Ninja
went from a hundred thousand to 20
million subscribers in the space of only
a year while setting multiple records
record World Records on Twitch
and still a Balenciaga and Still Remains
as the number one most followed streamer
on the site by almost double
however Ninja's career has certainly
been short-lived over the last three
years his president has faded
dramatically the downfall of fortnite
Battle Royale has been one of the main
factors there are numerous other poor
decisions that have played okay so let
me hold on
when he talked I wonder what the POI
poor decision he's talking about yeah I
gotta find this where he calls him out
for like
supporting black lives matter
see
which definitely isn't the reason
nobody's watching him bro
you remember that one time ninja was
like
it sucks that George Floyd was murdered
that's why I don't want
I'm pretty sure it mostly had to do with
him leaving twitch for like two years to
a platform that nobody was on yeah 100
that is all of it
um
or is it or which people slightly
obvious that there was a serious lack of
innovation and effort being put into the
YouTube videos most of his titles and
thumbnails are stating someone tells me
what
uh maybe can you screen it yeah
yeah thanks
so anyway that's what's going on
damn his social blade looked like ours
up until like this month
it's nice to see that
people actually care about it
because there's a lot of piece of shits
out there I probably love this video but
yeah
ultimately uh people but I'm glad to see
people expressing themselves
um
and that's that
that's that essentially
so uh remember guys
tomorrow at 2 30 we're going live for
members I am so excited
4. Creator Clash our boy a b is going to
bring the heat yes
I am so excited
there's also lots of other friends of
the show in the uh
and that is true
it's gonna be a lot of fun yeah we'll be
eating Popeyes apparently you see that
uh uh the super mega boys are doing the
national anthem that'll be fun
huh
what are you doing Shred
get on out of there
nowhere there it was exploring around W
Shredder he's bored he's bored he's
active he's like running around he's
exploring some good spirits oh it's all
wet oh
oh it's on the water
did Shredder do that
I just took them out he he peed no it
was over the
River oh did he flip it I think I think
you probably did oh little stinker oh
his bed was all wet a little stinker
he was laying on it too you poor boy
yourself
[Music]
what is this message
Ian said he had to go
try and get some stuff together for
Coachella but if Ethan notices I left
let them know I had to run have a good
weekend and ab is going to send dad to
the Florida swamp that's right yeah but
it's gonna be Gator food Gator food
that's right
uh did you happen to find that I don't
know if
you can watch it before Oh somebody
already made Dan as the Spirited Away
Guy so a common bone Fork W right there
this guy makes stuff so fast
oh it's animated yeah that's so sick
nice one bone for oh yeah that [__] yeah
yeah again yeah so anyway
so in short uh
trans rights
forever
Mr Beast is a great guy
great job Chris looking after yourself
despite
all the [__] you knew you would get and
are getting
and
and uh Babylon reach Babylon reach gay
Babylon reach is this the uh is this
what you just sent cam the uh timestamp
yep
so if you still care to watch it oh
great we got the time stamp okay so here
touch but more specifically why is he
even getting involved in politics at all
stay in your lane ninja there have been
numerous tweets over the last 12 months
relating to ninja standing with the
black community and his wife okay hold
on this literally said Justice for Floyd
like a dude who was murdered on video
and he's like yo what's with the black
community solidarity bro
any streams there are numerous tweets
over the last 12 months relating to
ninja standing with the black community
and his wife stating that ninja does his
part for white privilege and racism but
this just goes back to the previous
point of being ingenuine with his
audience how do you know it's 30 years
this is the same [__] they always say
about you right yeah
genuine no one can genuinely support
anything it's always cynical it's always
for cloud it's always a calculated yeah
the reason they say that is because they
can't imagine a world where they would
care about that stuff right so they
can't imagine a world where anyone else
would yeah
ninja is a multi-multi-millionaire white
guy spending his time playing video
games who also seems to be somewhat low
in compassion judging from the way he
treats his enemies after he kills them
dude he rages in fortnite
that's like why did he just say that
that was it that everybody yeah Play It
Again
that's crazy here let me go back
to be somewhat low in compassion judging
from the way he treated
well he rages in fortnite therefore he
has no compassion
whoa that is hold on is this guy like 18
like who is this guy yeah maybe I think
so I want to know who is this guy
sunnyv2 who doesn't believe [__] that's
right is there more known about this guy
like who is he uh he has a I looked up
his what is that website uh like
wikitubia or whatever and it had some
information here I'm gonna pull up a
picture of him
does it have his birthday
say his age on here this kid is like 16.
what are we listening to
is that him oh he's 26 okay he's old
enough to be too old to be he's from
Australia it does say Australia yeah he
is Australian
he's too young to be going uh yeah
there he is conspiracy theory Creator
number five
along with Shane Dawson
in Good Company thanks birthdays
okay I'll bite
I want to know my power rankings
YouTube Star thanks for saying that
about me okay
the fish eye is really not fair
oh my God
I'm only number seven for Ethan's how
many Ethans are out there there's no
other way this will be a fun game let's
think of the more famous Ethan Hawke
yeah Ethan hawksley
um Ethan Allen the furniture
Ethan Allen
there was those Ethan twins but I don't
think they've done Ethan Dolan but Ethan
Bradberry
that's a huge star
isn't there a director Ethan Cohen do
you think oh yeah yeah
I think he spells it differently though
but all right I'm just clicking it all
right let's see it let's see I haven't
seen him in a while
yeah
that's not a real person he was on that
show Shameless
[Music]
never heard of him see I'm more popular
than Ethan Hawke that's a long time but
you're not the most popular
YouTuber you're amongst a lot of
children yeah a lot of children
he's whacker than let me get you to the
top that's true
so is this just about how fans who spam
your [__] yeah okay so I was just silly
and stuff so let's get you to the top
right the top it's not even worth it
it's not even funny like wikiFeet yeah
who cares it's just sad
there's people who are okay okay I share
a birthday with all these people
me and Lele pons were
that's wonderful Wednesdays besties
anyone else your pictures killing me
wait you share a birthday with George
Michael
oh wow apparently I do man and Angela
from The Office me and Ricky just have
the same birthday you guys oh my God
Ricky Gervais yeah oh my God whoa you're
so special well oh Anthony Bourdain oh
my God you guys rip to the goat yo yo
Eric Carl he looks like no way Captain
Picard but it's not
yo this dude
I thought that was an island boy of
course yo NASCAR NASCAR
just NASCAR that's his name apparently
uh reaction creators Sniper Wolf number
one oh of course he is the queen yeah
topping that yeah this is a tough one
Dr Mike
no I can't let that stand
yeah I know third twenty dude you're
down bro well you actually don't do that
anymore uh still Matt what's up MattyB's
stats oh wait Trisha's stats I want to
see
I have to click it
more popular yo number one first name
Trish number one mukbang Creator way
more popular
number seven 34 year old
weren't you like 2 000
yeah that's really no 382. I was like
done I was even on the list number two
for May eight amazing wow crushing it
she is absolutely destroying me push
this site honestly oh wait oh here he
beats babies on here wait where do you
see Ava I just linked it is he the most
tell me he's the most popular a b he's
not on there too he's not
added himself
number one last name a odd okay first
name a b number two yeah sorry how many
are there there's four yeah
and they're dead
the number 25 film producer what wait a
minute
Harvey Weinstein
it's a who's who wait scroll down and ab
is on this list
he's yeah there he is
okay fantastic
better picture than mine you know how I
know AB uploaded this what is mine can
we look at mine no I'm just kidding
maybe didn't do that it's just a joke
that I make you look like we joke around
we like to play we joke around
number one Ewa okay
Benjamin Netanyahu
your brother's number three second baby
that's like nothingness wow let there be
more
I mean this website yeah doesn't seem
very comprehensive if we're being honest
they've got their finger on the pulse
let's be honest yeah you think so they
know what's happening
isn't there like models they're super
famous from Israel are they not from Tel
Aviv
uh might be from some other Town born in
Israel number six Natalie Portman Gal
Gadot I don't know who this guy is
ASMR Globe Facebook star Gene Simmons
my real name is I know he was Jewish but
I didn't know he was born in Israel
wait does Dan have one girl because I
don't like stream or anything like a b
well let's see someone maybe but it's
not my real name yeah
you gotta be the number one number one
fika yeah young fake uh number four born
in
Sweden you got it
uh
[Music]
young shopping Ian shopping you're the
number that was perfect
how about Jeff Dunham is he on here
ventriloquist
not comedian ventriloquist
tell me it's the number one number two
that should not be a category Darcy we
got a ventriloquy uh War out here on the
street Marcy let's not forget Edward
Bergen Edgar Bergen from 1903 to 1978.
Timeless timeless
I gotta say I'm impressed with Tricia's
stats he's a cultural tour de force he's
juicing
not a lot of famous Trish is out here
Instagram Starks give me a break Trisha
Malik Malik oh is that like Zayn Malik's
mother that's the mother of former One
Direction yeah oh my God she liked
Selena Gomez's uh Instagram post she's
number two
yeah she did and there's rumors that
that Selena and Zane are dating so
[Music]
then yeah do we love that
um we'll see if he makes her happy and
she seems comfortable we'll see yeah be
good as long as she's happy it's
literally all I care about
any other ones we want to check
um
no no Brian Kavanaugh Jimmy Lee [__] all
right guys listen
ing listen we've had a great times we've
had some uh hard times we've had good
times that make good times and bad times
make good bad times and week times make
weak men so true you sound like Rich
right now about insecurity yeah
yeah yeah
well members we'll see you tomorrow
tomorrow viewing party starts at 2 30.
can't wait to see you guys there's gonna
be a ton of fun
come on a b
come on
come on brother
you got this
[Music]
all right love you guys have a great
weekend but we will see you tomorrow
with your members so that's not for now
have a great weekend
thank you
[Music]